welcome to mlb game of the week pregame
show presented by jim beam the focus
will be the third of a three game set at
pnc park as the dodgers are taking on
the pirates the dodgers have won 12 in a
row against the pirates dating back to
june of 2018 it's one shot the longest
win streak over the pirates in franchise
history 13 straight way back in 1952
even before pops was planned la's
outscored pittsburgh 90 to 39 in the
last 12 meetings and the key thing for
the dodgers right now they're beat up on
bad teams they've won 17 of 19 games
against teams currently with the five
worst records in the nl d-backs pirates
rockies nats and marlins game time
coming up just about 30 minutes from now
dodgers and pirates on the way arias
versus keller adnan brick alongside the
great buckshow walter three-time manager
of the year so digging this up here 94
04 in 2014. that means 2024 you're due
for another manager of the yearbook
ain't going to happen
24. maybe 34. 30.
i'm playing with house money right now
we'll definitely talk about a lot with
the la dodgers today but first off the
highlights from yesterday in case you
missed it
and now facing a guy that has had a lot
of success against him and justin turner
that is a high fly ball deep center
field reynolds now out of room it's gone
on to one turner
flies one down the line to left
tom moves over to the corner he looks
and it's gone turner gets them again
turner two the pirates one
off tom's glove and into the seats
it feel bad for tom there but justin
turner getting those two home runs heck
of an effort there with the left fielder
here's how the standings look the giants
with that great starting pitching
they're in first place two games up on
los angeles the padres right there as
well two and a half games back and then
you've got the rockies and the d-backs
so the dodgers finally won the world
series buck first time since 1988 you go
into this season you go okay we're
locked and loaded got our talent ready
to go but they've had some issues some
injuries dealing with that championship
hangover how do you manage that as a
manager well that's why evan i've always
really respected people that did
won when you were expected to win it's
the hardest thing to do in team sports
because everybody's gunning for you
there's no little engine that could
sneaking up on anybody and let's face it
the dodgers don't have any complaints
they've got a talented farm system you
know self-induced in a good way and
they've got good players but as a as a
manager and you know a guy like turner's
a guy that you can count on but as a
manager you don't ever let some excuse
creep in you don't say woe is me
you walk in uh you know guys like chris
taylor are having big years they're
they're too behind in the lost town
that's the only thing i look at is lost
column i don't look at anything else but
that tells you over the course of season
we're all going to play the same games
they've got pitching that's solid you
got to trust all this and the last thing
you want to do is walk in a locker room
and go
and state the obvious and make it look
like you're not trusting what they're
capable of doing
i think they're actually in a good place
you like to come in and go guys listen
what what a great opportunity we have
here with people down to be who we are
and you always ask yourself in the off
off-season what if
what if this guy gets hurt what if this
guy
can't close games what if this guy
you know you're always going to go to
the what-ifs from the youth sometimes
the infusion you get from your youth and
you'd like all your what-ifs to come
from within your system and that's what
the dodgers are able to do yeah you look
at the injuries they've had obviously
bellinger got hurt corey seeger got hurt
mookie betts down here offensively
although he's still looking at but a
five and a half war and how about the
hall of fame import let's get albert
pools who still matches against lefties
well and the only the only reason he's
playing now is to win again you know he
doesn't have anything to prove or what
have you and uh you know he's like ef
hut and all of a sudden he decides to
say something everybody's going to
listen i remember when we brought our
colleague jim tomy into baltimore it was
like wow jim we're actually trying here
we're going we're not gonna leave any
stone unturned and the dodgers uh i i
just think the opportunity to stay
connected it's one of those things take
a shot at us now boys because when we
get all the you know the cowboys back
it's going to be tough yeah bulls is
slugging over 517 games of the dodgers
so to your point he's trying to win and
he's still effective like whatever
happened in los angeles was fine not an
everyday player but pools if you mix and
match him well he's effective well if
you're a manager and he's not starting
which he doesn't you know often
you know there's a there's a force over
on the bench coming off that bench right
that you can count on it's going to give
you a professional bat off you know the
really good hitters can hit the good
pitching late in the game right and if
you're a manager i know you're going
aren't when are they going to use pool
holes to make sure i've got something to
defend ourselves for that we looked at
those offensive ranks and it's great but
i just look at that pitching and go oh
my goodness like every time you all
right kershaw bueller gonslin's back now
you've got so many different options
there well they make runs matter good
pitching make runs matter it's nothing
worse than a dugout for hitters to go
okay how much is enough today how much
is enough wait wait a minute this game
was nine to two now it's nine six nine
seven come on it really weighs on you
how much is enough
they play defense and they pitch a
baseball and that's a great uh
combination to stay engaged and uh
they're gonna be there at the end we all
know that it's just a matter of how
quickly they get their people back yeah
two games back as you said that's what
you look at in the lost column the poll
question today as you're building up the
dodgers and pirates real simple who will
win today's game dodgers or pirates the
pitchers julio urias versus mitch keller
keller so far this season's had a
horrible year among the 132 pitchers at
least 40 innings this season only matt
harvey and matt shoemaker have a worse
era than keller so that could be good
news for the dodgers office could be a
tough day for the pittsburgh pirates
when we come back we'll keep it rolling
here about 25 minutes until first pitch
24 minutes be specific dodgers and
pirates justin turner's been one of
those guys who's been great he's batting
302 388 558 slug in his last 12 games
the two home run game on wednesday we'll
talk to jt but his state of affairs next
lifted to center field that goes
bellinger on the track leaping and
making the grab at the wall beautifully
done in center field by cody bellinger
lux it's a towering fly ball to right
field sending williams back and keeps
carrying out of the yard
it brings rain and a solo shot starts
the scoring
driven to right center field he's
already got one tonight make it two
gavin locks for the multi-homer game and
the dodgers lead seven four
one
hits the ball in the air back to right
that is gone
and this game is tied
[Applause]
bellinger hits one way up there
williams going back at the wall
goodbye
grand slam
game busted wide open
an 11 run first inning 14th pitch
driven to right center field
epic stuff
chris taylor unloads the bases on the
14th pitch
[Applause]
[Music]
the iconic roberto clemente welcome back
the mlb game of the week pregame show
presented by jim beam
look at the impact justin turner has had
with the los angeles dodgers in dodgers
history the highest ops with a minimum
of 3 000 plate appearances names like
mike piazz at the top of the list the
great duke snyder i mean you've got
jackie robinson there and there is
justin turner on that list awfully
impressive what he's done so far in
dodger blue and we welcome him in right
now justin i don't know if you can see
that graphic but highest ops three
thousand plate appearances you're on a
list you're top seven with names like
piazza duke snyder jackie robinson what
does that mean to you made an impact
there in los angeles
yeah that's pretty wild i didn't know
that that stat but uh to have my name on
a list with with those guys and and that
caliber player is obviously uh something
that's pretty special but you know being
a dodger special in the history of this
organization and the players that have
come through here that have changed the
game in so many ways not just on the
field but off the field as well it's
just uh it's always cool to have have
your name uh related with those guys hey
justin let's maybe a long question i'll
shorten it up but okay you sit there
there are they sprinklers working back
there for you
i'm getting rained on and there's not a
cloud in the sky right now so okay walk
the fans through last night you got a
night game day game 12 35 turn around
what you go through have you changed
clothes since you got off the bus
i have not i have not yeah i was uh i'm
usually one of the last guys at the park
uh i got back to the hotel like 1 1 30
last night and
i literally just got here today i'm
still in the clothes i wore
and uh we got a game in about two hours
so after this interview's over i'll go
change grab a quick bite and get in the
cage and get to work
justin how about okay let's go back when
i got to baltimore and you had just left
and i said what did we not like about
this guy you know what would you tell
guys you went with three clubs you were
a senior sign out of cal state fullerton
all the scouts love guys out there
because they play the game hard they
play the game right what would you tell
some of those guys out there that's that
the door hasn't opened for them yet
yeah i think uh the biggest message i
send to guys is all it takes is one one
particular guy uh to like you and if you
have that one guy in your corner
you know they can help prolong your
career and and uh you know that's that's
what happened to me i've been able to
bounce around to a few organizations
because one particular guy uh you know
kind of had his eye on me and and kept
me around so
uh there's a lot of people in this game
that that can tell you or that are gonna
tell you that you're you're not fast
enough or you're not strong enough or
you can't do this or you can't do that
uh but you know keep going because all
it takes is one guy to really like what
you're doing who was the guy
specifically with los angeles that
believed in you well in l.a i had i had
guys like uh
tim wallick who
who was a former titan come up to me and
asked me if i was uh what was going on i
told him i'm still a free agent
and then he took it back to the front
office and and said hey we should go try
it and take a shot on this guy so
uh timmy wallick was huge for for
getting me over here that's great as far
as last night's game was concerned
obviously a great game for you how about
that home run take me through it the
left fielder has a beat on it makes an
incredible attempt but yes it's gone
were you going like no no okay good what
was your reaction
yeah when i hit it it got in on me a
little bit so i kind of just dropped my
bat and put my head down and uh i
thought i flew out to left honestly and
then when i was around him first i saw
him jump up and the ball go flying out
of his glove and uh the way things were
going for me lately uh you know i'll
take that definitely so
um i'm just glad i wasn't running on
first base because that same play
happened earlier in the year with cody
bellinger and i was on first base and i
cost him a homer so
uh i'm just happy i wasn't on first base
when i hit that homer there
just ran back to first and pass myself
guys how do you guys keep that uh
competitive spirit after the things you
accomplished last year and you're
constantly everybody's giving you their
best shot and you're trying to get you
know the lure of mediocrity after a
great season you guys uh it's a
challenge isn't it
yeah it is a challenge and you know
this has been talked about in our
clubhouse and uh
you know one common theme that comes up
is uh you know we everyone just watched
that jordan documentary and they talk
about how uh no matter what he's going
through he just finds ways to motivate
himself whether
even when he's like making stuff up
right and that's what motivates him and
i think for us finding the motivation is
hearing people talk about oh you know it
was only a 60 game season
um and then the circumstances of the
playoffs and not being able to celebrate
not being able to have a parade so
there's a lot of stuff
that we feel like even though we won the
championship we missed out on and and
that's kind of driving us to you know
pursue that again and get to do it the
right way and get to celebrate it the
right way yeah motivation always comes
in many different forms i want to get
your thought jt on chris taylor i just
find this guy fascinating he plays
literally almost any position except for
pitcher and catcher and he's having a
great year offensively tell me about
chris taylor how does he do this
yeah he's uh he's just one of those you
know baseball guys and and like you said
you can put him anywhere on the field
you can hit him anywhere in the lineup
and he's he's the catalyst that's going
to do something every single night to
help us win a ball game it doesn't
matter whether it's defensively or some
of the abouts he puts together you guys
saw the 14 pitch at bat last week where
he hit the three-run double um you know
he hits for power he takes walks he uses
the whole field
he's an outstanding base runner i don't
know if you saw the play in atlanta the
other night um infield in and he's on
third uh ground ball to third baseman he
gets inside gets in the throwing lane
ball hits him in the back next thing you
know we score eight runs so uh the guy
just does everything extremely well he's
uh he pays attention to detail uh about
as good as anyone as i've ever played
with and uh he's a huge part of any
success that we've had so far well he's
a lot of fun to watch as are you day
game after night game never pleasant but
you look great i'm sure you'll crush
today appreciate the time man
thanks for having me fellas
push your favorite players to the top
this summer of the 2021 google mlb
all-star ballot phase one is underway
and runs through june 24th finalists
will be revealed on mlb network on june
27th vote daily mlb.com vote and on
google by searching mlb all-star vote to
send them to colorado
time now for the creators spotlight a
pleasure bringing cowboy jeff that's
right jeff reyes who's all about gaming
and sports videos of the mlb focus he
loves the dodgers and his favorite mlb
moment the steve philly walk off grand
slam to clinch the nl west october 2nd
about 4. i like the fact he went off the
board there because he just picked last
year and the dodgers triumphant women
going back to 0-4 a pleasure to bring in
cowboy jeff right now i want to first
talk with the all-star game because
that's where where focus is just about a
month or so from now who is the one
player right now you say i want to see
him in the all-star game
oh oh i mean there's so many i don't
want to be a homer but i mean i kind of
i kind of have to go i feel like maybe
max muncie max muncie he's put up quite
a year so far for us he's been
in my opinion the dodgers mvp so far
but uh if i could see max munsey in
there that'd be that'd be something for
sure no you nailed it jeff because you
look at the other first baseman right
now freddie freeman's a reigning mvp his
ops is a little bit under 800. you look
at the other perennial cannons alonso
also munchie's got an ops about 940 like
he's he's a runaway favorite right now
to be the starting first baseman that's
not being a homer that's being a good
pick by you
there you go i mean i'm glad i am i'm
glad my take wasn't completely uh
homerish completely out there but yeah
no max muncie
i mean just the thing like we picked him
up a few years ago
and from the a's and he wasn't really uh
he wasn't really i guess uh as big as he
is now and just for to see him
kind of climb and ascend and kind of be
the the first baseman that he is now to
make him see the all-star game that
would be uh
that would be my for sure that'd be
something my dream for sure yeah it
would definitely be awesome to see i
think it's got a good chance of
happening let's focus on you and
specifically what you're doing to your
youtube channel so it's a lot of focus
as far as gaming is concerned and when
mlb the show as i was telling you off
air i got it will be the show now for my
eldest son because we had an xbox before
it was only playstation now it's
available to both so i'm like all right
let's go tell me about your gaming
expertise particularly the mlb the show
well
expertise is kind of a strong word i'm
not i'm not really the greatest and will
be the show player
for me it's it's it's mostly i just try
to go out there try to have fun
uh try to if i could if i could live
vicariously through my road to the show
character and and bad flip and do all
kinds of crazy stuff like that for me
it's just all about having fun uh
honestly because i mean lord knows i'm
not really uh i'm not like one of those
top tier players like some of the other
mlb the show youtubers so gotta make up
for it with my uh with my personality i
suppose well i think the humility goes a
long way also you're big into weed
baseball there's some weed baseball
videos on the channel as well talk to me
about that
well uh wii baseball it's uh it's kind
of a nostalgic game for me i know i'm
gonna sound like a boomer saying this
but i know like that game came out when
i was 15-16
and just the uh the whole like just it
was completely foreign to me just like
having the the remote and and you know
taking hacks like you're a real baseball
player it makes me um it makes me really
appreciate
what it's like to be or to
to
what some of these players go through
because some of these weave baseball
pitchers they'd be throwing you 80 mile
per hour splitters and on the next pitch
they'll throw you a 104 mile per hour
fastball
it makes you want to throw the remote at
the tv
yeah you can definitely appreciate the
frustration that must be for actual
players much less gamers
i love the name cowboy jeff where did
this come from brian kenny here wears
cowboy boots we don't call him cowboy bk
but i like the fact you're known as
cowboy jeff where did it stem from
uh cowboy jeff it
kind of came from uh
my good friend bobby crosby he plays uh
he has his own channel dodger films and
uh
i think on a it was a halloween special
we were playing so we were all getting
in costume and all that
and uh i guess just one one of those one
of those days i was gonna go to a party
as a cowboy and i i showed bobby like
hey bobby i'm gonna come up to the game
uh dress as a cowboy like no you gotta
you gotta you gotta be a cowboy forever
now that's that's such an awesome look
on you
and uh and to be honest i know the my
first at-bat uh i had the poncho on and
i felt like it kind of fixed my my swing
a little bit like i like i was able to
swing better in a poncho and a hat
is
uh but yeah that's it's
not really too too i'm not an actual
cowboy
um
but that's pretty much how he got the
name so you're not an actual cowboy you
just play one on youtube i thought maybe
you're a big fan of toy story a fan of
tom hanks but the woody character but
maybe that was the direction we were
going in but listen cowboy that's
actually that's part of the reason why i
was uh i was a cowboy that year um for
halloween that's actually my top i'll
say top three favorite movie of all time
toy story for sure i mean
it's a great film and the rarity with
toy story is the the actual sequels are
just as good i mean toy story 3 is going
to be the best of the bunch and that's
very rare you ever say the trilogy is
the best of the bunch so we agree there
on toy story to infinity and beyond we
continue with steve finley i love this
choice this is your favorite walk-up
moment because there's so many others
you could have pointed to especially
last season as a dodgers guy what is it
about that finley walk-off that stands
out to you
well
that's that honestly that holds such a
special place in my heart because
i've been a dodger fan since 2000
and i remember up until that point we
hadn't made the playoffs since 1980 we
hadn't won a game a playoff game since
1988
and
i just remember it was i think it was
like the second to last game of the
season
it was going down to the wire with the
giants and i remember we were plugging
away we were down by three runs in the
ninth inning and i was in my friend's uh
apartment complex at the time
and i'm like are we really gonna do this
are we really gonna come back in the
ninth inning and i remember our guys
were just taking good at bats just just
getting on base and then steve finley
just with that magic grand slam putting
them away i mean i remember the whole
apartment complex just it just
it seemed like it exploded honestly it
was uh it was nuts it was just it was a
for me it's just like kind of burned
into my memory forever and um
i know this is kind of like uh this is
also kind of like a 1b moment for me but
uh jose lima
who passed away i think not too long ago
he got us our first ever playoff win
uh that series against the cardinals in
2004 and i just love i think that's how
i want to play on my youtube channel
just kind of with the passion jose lima
had i remember him lima time and he he
was out there with so much passion and
so much fire i mean it's it's one of
those things that stays with me to this
day yeah he was a ton of fun to watch at
the right with that exuberance out there
lima time was always a good time i've
actually met steve finley i called the
celebrity softball game a few years ago
he was in the game very humble very down
to earth so if i ever see him again i'm
like you know what cowboy jeff big fan
of that grand slam thanks for being on
the show and seriously best of luck with
the channel and go dodgers
thank you go dodgers and uh thank you
for having me i really appreciate it
all right cowboy jeff not an actual
cowboy coming up next though dodgers and
the pirates the dodgers of when each of
julio orios's four career appearances
against pittsburgh he's been great
against them you can see turner right
now stretching out looking pretty good
we got our picks to click coming up
we'll put buck on the spot little over
under when it comes to the game today
he's fearless you'll want these picks
next
and another one of those delayed steals
he got the tag on him he's out yeah
that's a tough play by cool wow reynolds
switch hitter batting left one two is
blasted to right deep toward the wall
god home run for brian reynolds
[Applause]
with his eighth run of the year ties the
game at one
that's just hard to center field setting
martay back to the track to the wall
clear the deck with a cannonball
the kid keep ryan hayes
you've got to be kidding me charlie
and now they're loaded for stallings
line drive to left field this is gonna
get down
jacob stallings the cheetah just doubled
in one
two
and three runs
how about that
ball center field that'll do it walk it
off cheetah you're hungry go eat and
raise the jolly roger
what a grind it out win in 12 for the
battle in bucks an 8-7 victory the
pirates win the first three games of
this four-game series against the
marlins
[Music]
raise the jolly roger raise it welcome
back to mlb game of the week pregame
show presented by jim beam
time now for picks to click presented by
bet mgm you saw justin turner out there
talking a little shop you think they
were talking college world series don't
you had a doubt adam frazier we were
having them on the other day they're
believe me they're locked and loaded
they are locked and loaded first
question here for buck are the dodgers
still your favorite to represent the
national league in the world series yes
but i think i'd love to see the padres
there too because i think it'd be great
for baseball it's really a but it'd be
good if the dodgers got there too i love
people that can repeat i still think
they're they're the favorite yeah i
think to me the surprise here is the
mets are actually a plus 500 considering
the injuries that they've had the mets
still being third braves i still think
are going to turn around brewers i don't
know but their starting pitch has been
great that's why i believe in the
brewery i agree with the mets though
because i think they are in position to
make some trades to really strengthen
that club for what they may need
surprised the cubs not in the top five
cubs right now best record in the
central i'm not sure about their
starting pitching yet yeah i'm not sold
yeah and that's one of the reasons why i
like the giants is they're starting
pitching again though tough division
there are the dodgers and the padres all
right which dodger has the best shot at
the nlmvp award i would like to say
chris taylor because what he's meant to
that club moving all over the place but
a lot of people wouldn't consider him
sexy enough even though some people
disagree with me yeah but i like walker
bueller and throw all that out i just
think at some point
i think the pitching is such a separator
for them and i think he's getting ready
to have a monster year all the way
around and really uh have people
understand i know pitchers aren't
supposed to win the mvp but if you ask
those guys in the club what's been there
a rock it's been those starting pitchers
that have have had somewhere i think the
three or three starting pitchers with 14
or 15 wins already yeah and it's pretty
remarkable their depth on starting
pitching but statistically right now
it's bueller and baub in the stars but
listen verlander's won an mvp kirsten
we've seen guys do it in the past you're
right it's not like it's an anomaly it's
interesting you mentioned taylor six
different positions he's played who's
the guy you managed you said i could
literally put him in any different
position well you know i think that
that's a position that utility guy is a
position the uh long reliever used to be
a position the backup catcher was a
reposition
and uh probably randy velarde years ago
i'm going way back randy would go
anywhere and steve pearce was the guy
that would play hey steve you ever
played second base no let me go work on
a little bit while i'll do it at seven
o'clock you know what does the team need
you gotta take your ego out of it to do
it and chris taylor does that chris
taylor's not even not even on the board
right now for the odds that's how
shocking this is if you ask if you ask
dave roberts who's been his most
valuable guy that he could count on to
plug in everywhere and not take a step
back it might be chris taylor he has
been great kershaw by the way plus ten
thousand over under total run scored in
today's game the number is eight orios
has been excellent keller's been
terrible day game after night game how
do you size it up i'm gonna go believe
it or not under because i know as on a
day like this you're the manager you got
two pots of coffee walking around going
you have a cup you have a cup i mean
it's it's a challenge to be ready and
you got to be careful about sleepwalking
early in this game especially the
dodgers on paper you think they would
win the game easily but this is a game
where you get on the bus going back and
go what just happened yeah and your
point of the time 12 35 eastern that's 9
35 for the dodgers right it's 13 hours
since they played last it's a it's a
challenge but it's part of the job
description you know what time we play
as jim tommy used to say buck what time
they play in that song that anthem i'll
be there yeah exactly be ready uh over
under how many outs will julio aureus
record you see him warming up right now
the number is 17 and a half so basically
five and two thirds you take it over or
under i'm going over i think he's going
to pitch six putts even with a 14-man
pitching staff don't get me started they
they have some need to have some length
and he's uncharacteristically going to
be asked to go a little deeper today
maria says 2-0 allowing two runs and 13
total innings against pittsburgh overall
a 1.38 era so he's been just electric
against them overall i mentioned that
stat earlier too they've won 17 of 19
against teams of the five worst records
in nl there's two ways you can look at
this some people go oh so they beat up
in the bathrooms that's why they're good
but the other option is no they just win
the games they're supposed to win who
cares
without a doubt you know w's a w they
don't say okay you only get half a win
there because you beat this team and
when you look back at your season you
should beat the people you need to beat
and but unfortunately when the season's
one-third of the way through roughly
where it is you don't know who the good
and bad teams are you're not gonna pick
that up to about the two-thirds because
somebody that's not doing well right now
is all sudden gonna emerge here in the
next couple of weeks it's move-in month
june is moving much i agree we were
looking at the division leaders right
now if i see the okay a's white sox rays
giants comes mets that's all the way
it's going to be i think the giants will
slip a little bit dodge will catch them
who knows what else could happen arias
will get the call today how about the
poll results real simple question we
asked you off the top basically who's
going to win dodgers or pirates right
now dodgers you think in the driver's
seat you've got 86
of the poll results they're saying the
dodgers will be triumphant against the
pirates interesting by the way i want to
go back to what you're saying about
a pitcher potentially winning how about
if jacob de graham go in the mvp i mean
point seventeen
i mean he's got my attention all right
you know i i got in a situation where
and i loved it i got to actually watch
him pitch five or six things non-stop
not interrupted yeah wow you kidding me
i don't care oh that that's impressive
last pitch when mvp was kershaw back in
14. i heard this in mlb network radio
more likely
degrom beats bob gibson the 1.12 era in
68 or the mets he makes a world series
start for the mets which one is more
likely
pretty tough question
and your answer was i was like well
what's three
how about neither
exactly neither might be the way to go
but one point one two to me feels like
impossible yeah right i think he wins
the third saw young and the mets make
the world series not so sure about that
one thought on pittsburgh by the way i
know it's a struggling team young team
but a guy that i love is key brian hayes
charlie hayes is kid you watch him out
there isn't he electrifying player he in
a lot of ways he reminds me i know who
his father was i had charlie in new york
but uh
he's got a good face good scouts talk
about at that bottom it hears his assets
his negatives and at the bottom it goes
other it's they say he's got a good face
you know what he's talking about he's
got energy energetic eyes he's got
engagement he sees things around him he
needs to see first base a little bit
better yeah but you know what the great
thing about that because they come up so
fast that will never ever happen to
history hitting 362 in his career that
was a crazy moment though like how do
you how do you not touch first base hey
it happens you'll see key brian hayes
and the pittsburgh pirates taking the la
dodgers for bucks show up from adnan
vert scott braun and the fellas with the
call enjoy it on youtube
keller will be on the mound against
julio urias let's do this game time next
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you kidding me
[Applause]
a warm day in downtown pittsburgh a
beautiful city home to one of the most
picturesque parks on the planet with a
chance to show off its digs to the world
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by jim beam it's the
defending world champs the los angeles
dodgers against the pittsburgh pirates
at pnc park in pennsylvania to complete
a three-game set the dodgers have taken
the first two hello to everyone watching
worldwide on youtube i'm scott braun
stationed in the studio and we have our
analysts stationed around the country
jerry hairston jr out in california sean
casey's at the ballpark in pittsburgh
sean played for pittsburgh jerry played
for la and jerry you're up first with
the dodgers the visiting team they're
the world champs from a year ago and it
hasn't been the smoothest start but
they're in good shape in the division
and who's been the rock thus far
well max muncie has been outstanding we
call him that funky muncie he leads the
team in home runs
outstanding job of squaring the baseball
up ops as well leads the national league
with 45 based on balls and 420 on base
percentage he has been a rock both
offensively and defensively we asked him
to play third base second base and he's
playing first base today he has been the
rock for this lineup max munsey
continues to improve his offensive
prowess in the lineup but overall the
dodger office even though the home runs
have been up this year the runs per game
has been up first to the national league
with 5.2 runs a game and he of the home
runs only 75 home runs so far this
season yeah it's a bit of a different
flavor but it still tastes good for the
dodgers so far the flavor of the pirates
well it's it's building mode right now
case as they try and pick up a game in
this series but there is some major
potential star power for them to build
around and it starts with
cabrian hayes man this guy's an absolute
stud and when they drafted him they
thought they were going to get the power
they knew they were going to get the
defense but he came up last year with a
small sample size and absolutely
delivered i mean you look at his 2020
season 376 this guy can run the bases
he's got great speed but the power is
what's really coming about with key
brian hayes hits the ball to dead center
early on in the year uh in the opening
day against the cubs he went deep and
then he got hurt but he's back in that
lineup and they really need him he can
flap he's gold glove right now
defensively this guy can flat out go get
it you see this play to his left he's
got a candidate of an arm so they're
looking for big things from him uh you
know this season and beyond but i tell
you what
they he's gonna help out these two's got
two guys in the order that have already
been doing it adam frazier look at this
leads both in doubles and hits brian
reynolds this guy's been doing it all
year long and they're both getting on
base so having these top three these
three guys at the top of that lineup
makes the pirates a lot better and we'll
see what they what they do today but but
as as the pirates go this top of the
order goes frazier reynolds and brian
hayes yeah that's the top three for the
pirates they also have excellent relief
pitching mitch keller will be on the
mound against julio urias let's do this
game time next on youtube
[Music]
three one
crossed down the line forget about this
one
a little bit lower than where it ends up
it ends up right down the middle there's
no miss in that swing that is total
barrel 14 pitch
right center field
epic stuff
chris taylor unloads the bases on the
14th
[Applause]
[Music]
cabrera to break a 3-3 tie in the six
with his third extra base hits
that's fair
one run comes in here comes another
chris taylor
knocks in a couple more and it's 7-1 now
8-1
he clears the bases with a double
[Applause]
so count me back
[Music]
blue
welcome back to pittsburgh where we
observe the dodgers 2020 season best
described as award-winning so how about
we appreciate it with the help of film
once upon a time in hollywood that movie
started brad pitt he was in a different
baseball movie how about this how the
west was won eight straight division
titles for the los angeles dodgers the
third longest streak in baseball since
divisional era began as good as it gets
best record in mlb best just about
everything in mlb the right stuff the
postseason begins the dodgers sweep
their way through the wild card series
and division series showing true grit
the nlcs coming back from a 3-1 deficit
and then finally la la land the
championship their first in la since
1988 scott back to you
jp that was award winning excellent job
we'll talk again in a moment the jim
beam dodgers starting nine for dave
roberts and the defending champs begins
with mookie betts max muncie on a roll
since may one justin turner homer twice
yesterday then a ton of lefties in a row
bellinger beatty mckinstry lux barnes is
at catcher today and urias will be
pitching for the dodgers and hitting in
the nine spot
let's get going
it's the pirates and the dodgers live on
youtube we're underway a fastball
delivered upstairs to mookie betts to
start the day here in the first
mookie going over five yesterday you can
see on the five game trip three for his
last 22.
we spoke to dave roberts about it this
morning
as he said he's missing some baseballs
through the zone and not ending at bats
here's mitch keller on the mound for
pittsburgh era is third worst in the
sport minimum of 40 innings case but the
talent is there it's just about fastball
command as the 2-0 is socked to center
field
reynolds heading back gives it a look
forget about it
third pitch of the game mookie betts go
long his sixth of the year it's one
nothing dodgers
[Music]
wow you said it you said it best right
there scott talking about mitch keller's
fastball command that ball was right
down the middle at 93 miles an hour you
can't miss the mookie bets right down
the middle he's going to make you pay
and uh if keller doesn't hit his spots
it could be a long day
look at this swing right here a 2-0 fast
ball center cut mookie bets does there's
that missed it right down the
says thank you very much let's get on
the board
so there's a strike to muncie 25th
career lead-off home run for mookie go
ahead jerry
yeah good to see mookie best get on a
fastball he's been struggling with
fastballs and manager dave roberts
talked about it today with us earlier
really hard to get on top of the
fastball he certainly got on top of that
fastball that time
and jerry he went to center field
and we spoke to dave this morning about
the pull power that mookie has but
that time he's going to a deep part of
the ballpark and showing off a little
bit more of his opposite field skills
absolutely pop for pound maybe one of
the strongest baseball players around
i see a ball inside right there you know
five foot nine about
170 pounds he has tremendous power to
all fields
mookie betts with sick bat speed and max
muncie has the eye of a champion
and he fouls that one off he leads the
national league in walks
also leads the nl with his 420 on base
percentage
you mentioned the walks there
scotty he certainly has a great eye but
this past month or so he's been
aggressive especially up in the zone
looking to drive the ball
he strikes out on some high heat from
keller
let's have a look at the bet mgm odds
today total runs
eight
over under do we think this is going to
be a high scoring affair jerry what do
you think about the run line today
well that's uh a generous over right
there over eight i think it's going to
be around eight
i know keller struck a little bit with
his command
but the dodgers are looking to swing the
bat here
and the thing with the dodgers offense
lately it's been streaky but
in about the past week
we've seen them explode for a
double-digit run inning we've also seen
them on friday put up eight against the
braves that one's up the middle justin
turner has himself a knock as he keeps
the momentum going from yesterday
case justin turner yesterday with two
homers he loves hitting off tyler
anderson and that theme continued he had
a multi-hit performance and he's locked
in
[Music]
he was his batman when when turner gets
going when you see him hit the ball the
ballpark center field left field this is
where he's the best of going back up the
middle that's a great sign for the
dodgers right there
he's got one of the prettiest
right-handed swings you'll ever
see now it's bellinger taking a breaking
ball for a strike
cody's missed some time this season
around seven weeks looking to get his
timing back in the batter's box but once
his timing is back he's as deadly a
hitter as there is
the kids call him cody love here
on the west on the west coast jerry i'm
gonna rely on you for all of the
nicknames i was watching you yesterday
too give
justin turner something i hadn't heard
before i believe it was dream red as
ballinger strikes out on three pitches
good fastball from keller to beat him
[Music]
well he's got a variety of nicknames
he's mr jt especially when he has
multi-homer games we also call him the
red dream
that's a pretty good fastball up in the
zone to get
bellinger that's what they'd like to see
more of
from mitch keller
fastball command wasn't a huge issue for
him in the minor leagues
and then in the major league so far
there's been a bevy of walks
to his line the past couple seasons
and also some misses over the plate and
if you do that to this dodger team case
you're in trouble
you're definitely in trouble you know
one thing when you watch keller pitch it
looks like he doesn't attack the zone
sometimes you know i think that's where
you talk about fastball command you know
he's kind of dancing a little bit so you
know for mitch keller he's got to be
right on because if if he misses today
the dodgers will make him pay
even though the dodgers are a patient
group
they're hunting pitches up in their zone
especially middle to play so they're
going to try to get into favorable
counts
especially against young pitchers like
keller
now bringing the good stuff good life on
his fastball he lasted just two innings
on friday against miami gave up a couple
hits and a pair of runs left the game
early with heat illness it ended up
affecting him with his stomach as well
at some stomach issues they placed him
on the covet injured list for a couple
days everything checked out okay
and he's back in action on turn for this
outing
that's sent to left field
tom right there
to put away the dodgers but not before
mookie betch strikes to start the day
third pitch of the afternoon
[Music]
and this is the bat speed the quick
hands
the former mvp putting the dodgers on
the board first
[Music]
this is hard to center field setting
marte back to the track to the wall
clear the deck with a cannonball
the kid keep ryan hayes
you've got to be kidding me charlie
and a line drive past third for key
brian hayes
6-2 that wasn't just a seeing high
ground ball i mean you hit that kind of
that two more in
two hits tonight for hayes on base for a
third time
two run homer in the first
hard to right back cooper
and looking up and it's off the wall
another rocket to right field for key
brian hayes into third with a trip trip
triple and welcome back
he's two for three
[Applause]
hayes with a fly ball toward left center
field dickerson is over and that's in
the gap
keep ryan hayes
into second base with a lead off double
you can't keep him down
top of the zone just a great swing
i don't remember ever seeing a guy start
like he has
dodgers up a run already it's the jim
beam starting lineup for the hometown
pittsburgh pirates adam frazier leads
baseball and hits key brian hayes brings
the bat and the glove he's been great
since coming off the injured list ryan
reynolds is the switch hitter jacob
stallings having his best offensive
season then there's evans gonzalez tom
newman with his contact and keller in
the nine spot
marias deals to fraser fastball misses
away and it's 1-0 julio reyes making his
13th start of this season era in the mid
threes last time out was friday a win
against atlanta five innings and one run
he's been excellent he's been giving
this team much more length this season
as well
frazier fouls it back and let's go over
the keys
for urias presented by jim beam jerry
you know the keys to ferraris and really
for the dodgers ureas has to pitch deep
in this ball game last night turned out
to be a bullpen game so we need at least
six or seven innings out of iris
early offense got that
with mookie betts
and if you're curious a left-handed
pitcher
you cannot let right-handed hayes beat
you he's got tremendous power
key brian hayes
on deck
frazier unfazed with two strikes as he
has 78 hits on the season riding a
12-game hit streak at the moment and a
big bounce back for him you have to keep
in mind
case that last year was just a 60 game
season there were a few bats in this
lineup that just never got it going then
you start pressing because you know the
end is near just a 230 batting average
last year for frasier as he fouls
another one off
yeah i think derek shelton was talking
about that before the game that you know
once you struggle sometimes as a player
you try and get those three four hits
that next game and with a 60 game season
you just never catch up adam frazier
this year has really come out with that
short swing got hot early and he's never
stopped
especially today's ball game with a lot
of guys trying to lift the baseball try
to hit home runs
frazier's a throwback contact guy
looking to go the other way doesn't
strike offense
offense excuse me offense
so he's been outstanding putting the bat
on the baseball
look at this battle
from adam frazier trying to work up that
pitch count statcast powered by google
cloud
adam frazier knows how to swing the bat
and earlier today derek shelton told us
i've never seen anyone as short to the
baseball as fraser you can see red hot
good
cold bad there's a lot of red
on this batting average by zone
there's no way to pitch this guy really
it's that up and in is where you get
them and you got them ria's got them out
front right there but frazier's really
covered the whole plate and covered
every zone so far this season
he takes what he's given but that time
nicely done by iriz to win the battle
it's the dodgers defense presented by
jim beam maria is playing catch with
barnes muncie mckinstry lux turner
infield beatty bellinger and betts
outfield
[Music]
and really you have two center fielders
out there with cody bellinger and mookie
betts they can go get it
inside to hayes and also keep in mind
that in pittsburgh
it is the largest left field territory
in mlb so there will be extra work extra
running perhaps for beatty this
afternoon
and that's
where how that comes in
met
matt beatty doesn't play a whole lot of
left field so cody ballinger should be
shading a little bit toward left center
field
to help baity because you know you have
mookie in right
hayes with a drive left center bellinger
giving it a look and it's going to kick
up off the wall
key brian hayes will head to second base
with a stand up one out double
great at bat right there by hayes i mean
you go look go back and look at that
ureas tries to come middle in first with
the fastball then he drops a change up
on him away gets in the 2-0 and then he
gets right here he kind of throws
another change up and this right here
you know jerry in the big leagues when
you get a change up that doesn't do have
much action and it stays up man it's
like a bp fastball cabrion hayes does a
great job of staying through it and
driving it to left center
it was a hanging cambio right there by
yurious and hayes was all over it very
fortunate furious that he kept it in the
yard
number three hitter brian reynolds
i think i see a little bit more often
for julio more of the breaking ball
first pitch changeup to keep these
pirates hitters
off balance
those two have been his most dominant
pitches you see the curve ball is how he
starts reynolds it's more of a slurve
second pitch he goes after it center
field drifting back bellinger to make
the catch
hayes will tag up
bellinger just coming back from that leg
injury
showing his great range right there
going back on the ball
he's as good as it gets in center field
as far as going back on the baseball
[Music]
yeah dave roberts told us about it
pretty good show hair too yeah show hair
elite defense
and hasn't completely
turned it on yet the 2019 mvp but his
manager actually gave us a prediction
that he said we could use today he goes
cody's going deep on a hanging breaking
ball this afternoon book it
[Music]
there's doc right there in the shades
career 391 hitter there in pittsburgh
doc could swing it man you know we talk
about his stolen base but he could swing
it a little bit too
yeah you could swing it hey this is a
guy right hey brony this is a guy right
here that you know that that's been
really got a chance to play stallings
you know they love him as a gold glover
behind the disc but he's really swung
the bat well for the pirates this
year lux will throw across athletic play
to complete the first
and hayes is stranded at third marias
and the dodgers up one nothing after one
keep ryan hayes hitting 348 now
on the season
it's this hard the other way to stay
fair
it is gone it hit the pole an opposite
field home run
for key brian hayes
dodgers are
either asking for a review of the home
run or they also appealed first base he
did miss first
they're calling him out that's
unbelievable
holy smokes
[Applause]
follicle third two gone mookie best
swats this one in the air right center
field that goes reynolds still going
lays out can't get it up against the
wall pollock can walk home that's
sprinting for third with an rbi triple
dodgers lead at two nothing
that pitch is drilled left center field
forget about it home run chris taylor
sounded like a shotgun going off
eighth of the season for taylor and the
dodgers lead five nothing
[Applause]
six seven and eight do up for the
dodgers in the second here's a look at
mitch keller and the inconsistencies
we've seen so far this season a
breakdown some starts he's electric
others
he's searching and fastball command is
the story let's set up the jim beam keys
for the pittsburgh pirates case
well i think that's the key right here
mitch keller he's got to throw strikes
you know he has 26 blocks and only 44
innings pitched that's really not going
to get it done but that's going to be
the key today top of the order
production we saw brian hayes already
has that big hit early in the game that
has to be huge for them and the bullpen
consistency for derrick shelton he's
been able to go to those guys at
rodriguez at the back end they've been
they've been really good so they got to
be consistent again today
we had a nice chat with derek shelton
this morning
i love his demeanor and
he knows what he's working with right
now
the pirates checking in at 23 and 37
they had the worst record in the
national league last year
they're still building themselves back
so you have to bring that positive
attitude all the good vibes every day to
the ballpark and
utilize your job not just as trying to
win games but also teach and develop
baseball players
and he's very intelligent you know he's
got a southern illinois background
education
so you know he knows his game where did
you go to school jerry
i also went to southern illinois there
we go
i made jared had a baby
look at those shades just a good looking
beast right there
only the kind of zach mchistory up for
the dodgers
he reminds me of a better looking veg
version
of skip schumacher same swing same
approach at the plate
but way better looking
what do you hey jerry what do you like
about him you know you get a chance to
see this guy a lot what do you like most
about
mckinsey he's a throwback a scrapper
type a great bat ball to ball skills
and he could play anywhere defensively
now he's really developed himself as an
outfielder too can play seconds i'm
short
he's kind of a poor man ct3 right now
third strikeout for keller
here's a look at the jim beam defensive
alignment for the pirates keller and
stallings the battery eric gonzalez at
first for colin moran who was hit by a
pitch yesterday frazier and newman the
double play combo hayes at the hot
corner has a
sweet glove tom reynolds evans from left
to right in the outfield
and now it's gavin lux 23 years old he
has taken off since taking over as the
starting shortstop for the dodgers since
corey seeger went down in mid-may with a
fractured right hand
and scott he's really grown up
knowing that corey seeger was lost for
at least a month six weeks so this
dodger team needed him he swung the bat
on cue
rocket to left through the left side
he's on with a one-out single
but he's been solid defensively as well
as offensively so he's starting to grow
uh into that player that dodgers knew he
could become
well when i when i watched lux when he
first came up i was like man this kid
really uses the whole field that was a
case right there got a change of away
does a great job visually of letting
that ball travel and shooting at the
left
especially in today's game with so many
shifts if you can handle a bat there are
so many picks out there
and that's why when seeger went down
the dodgers really don't skip much of a
beat 36 wins 25 losses a very
competitive national league west they're
two games back the first place giants a
half game better
than the san diego padres one of their
newer rivals in the division
and you got austin barnes at the plate
right here
the kids call him the real a b does an
outstanding job handling the bat
and handling the pitching staff
[Music]
jerry i heard teammates also call him
sam a story that goes back to
chase otley's days with the team when he
was telling him to grab some food and aj
ellis at the time on the dodgers said
you don't even know his name and utley
joke yeah i do it's sam
and it stuck too
and chase utley's still around
in the la area
but you're right you know he was a great
leader for this dodger team
and sam
also known as austin barnes has become
quite a leader himself
and a four pitch walk
to abort now for the dodgers
jp
how competitive is this nl west even
more so maybe than we thought
i think so the giants have changed
everything scott you look at this
division within the national league the
top three teams in run differential
among any nl team all three of them
right now are in the national league
west of course led by the surprising san
francisco giants all those names on the
old world series winning teams posey and
crawford belt for a while certainly all
contributing in a big way it's made the
dodgers bid to repeat all the more
challenging
we had the giants on youtube a couple
weeks ago i believe the final tally was
19-4
their win over cincinnati it's a team
that has done a really nice job of
picking up starting pitchers this
off-season that's a foul ball
don't worry but also the giants have
some sneaky bats both veterans that have
kind of hit their prime again in buster
posey and brandon crawford
and then some new guys as well like mike
ustremski i know jerry you get to see
the giants quite a bit how surprised are
you with their production
a little bit surprised especially their
starting pitching has been outstanding
in case you know this anytime you get
great starting pitching you're in every
ball game and then scotty as you
mentioned
the rebirth of buster posey
and evan longoria has had an outstanding
season so far so they're playing good
baseball
that's a fair ball and urias will
advance both runners nice job on the
bunt i saw him do that last week on
friday against the braves to spark the
beginning for the dodgers it was
actually a suicide squeeze at the time
that scored a run so rhys does his job
again this afternoon and two are in
scoring position
all about the fundamentals lucky here
cooler does a great job getting it down
and even though it's a little bit of a
pop-up it's down
soft bunt
all about the execution
that's like my lob wedge right there
case
on the green
get the job done just gotta
just gotta put it from there jerry you
just gotta put it from there
now that's the problem yeah that's had
the homer in his first ab
case should or jerry well i'll go to you
first case should brian hayes be playing
even closer to rhys on that play knowing
what's coming
i don't you know what that he was in he
was still in i don't think he should
have been any closer but he was he was
still in and the ball kind of fell in
that bermuda triangle and just got down
just enough that hayes couldn't get it
and julio is also a good athlete he can
handle a bat
if hayes is charging
he has the go ahead to go slash
from dave roberts so you got a chance to
add the third baseman you got to lay
back a little bit
make sure he gets the butt down and then
make the play
statcast powered by google cloud mookie
bets on pitch number three of the day
loved all of that one
417 feet to deep central
[Music]
i just love that swing by mookie betts
great show chain right there outstanding
top hand i think that's the key to his
swing when he finishes swing
that's when you see the power
it looks like keller is pitching him
really careful here it's almost like the
the the intentional
unintentional walk you know they're not
really looking to give much right their
little curveball 3-1 on the outer half
and you got max muncie on deck so
don't be too careful and turner after
that homework twice yesterday
oh boy
hitters count
did he go
he did
full boat
that's pretty good
3-1 pitch
looking for the fastball got the slider
slider is the second most used pitch in
the arsenal for keller fourth seam
dominates and that time that one just
missed almost landed in the zone by
accident but it's ball four to bets
you got to give keller some
you got to give keller some credit right
there because he comes here with a 3-2
curveball
looks like he might have got the top of
the zone right there
you know obviously the umpire didn't
give it to him but he pitched mookie
betts tough right there didn't give in
to him was giving him sliders and
curveballs and barely walked him in the
end
and up comes max muncie who's been the
dodgers best overall hitter 13 bombs on
the season
good fastball inside
from keller
[Music]
that's that's surprising 182 career
hit her with the bases loaded
and just in general this season
muncie is two for his last 17 and now
two strikes against him and he's mad
about it
this is what they want keller to do with
the fastball establish the fastball in
obviously they're attacking monksy in 95
in 96 in another one right here but if
you're gonna get it into muncie you
better bury it just like he did where
muncie wasn't able to get to it
[Music]
base is loaded big pitch from keller
and he misses inside
that's pretty good slider there at 87
miles an hour by keller
you see the defensive shifts right there
on muncie
muncie the last couple weeks done a
pretty good job with two strikes going
the other way
look for him to try to get something up
shoot it to left field
he does shoot that ball to deep right
but it's twisting and it is
a long
foul ball wow
wow muncie wants that pitch back because
that was a hanger if he waits a tick
longer that's why this is a game this
game is a game of inches man if he waits
a tick longer that pulls in the river
fair
yeah
i i said left field but he looked like
he was looking to go to philadelphia
with that swing
he was
[Music]
man he's he's come inside to muncie
almost on every pitch you wonder if he's
gonna try and do something soft away or
does he continue to pound him inside
you're right case if i'm max i'm kind of
looking out there
everything has been in maybe to keep me
honest maybe a fastball or a breaking
ball away
one two on its way
that's a spinner
and that'll twist out of play
nah he continues looks jerry to come
back in there 98 again down and in
but you know i know i know as a hitter
if i'm being attacked and you keep
attacking me in you know you're you're
trying to deceive me as a hitter if i
keep cnn man at some point i feel like
i'll be on it so that's why i say it
should be interesting to see if keller
and stallings don't try and go away at
some point but looks like the approach
right now is attack them inside hard
yeah either away or in off the plate
got him to pop it up
tom has it
and the inning is over
dodgers leave the bases loaded they do
have one from the bets homer in the
first as we head to the pirates half of
the second
[Music]
and now facing a guy that has had a lot
of success against him and justin turner
that is a high fly ball deep center
field reynolds
room it's gone
home run justin turner continues to
master tyler anderson his second home
run against him his tenth of the year
two aboard for polanco
line off the glove of pujols runner
waved home the throw to the plate he is
gonna be safe
what a slide if it holds up for reynolds
right to that edge
beat first
and snuck in there justin turner who
homered in the first down his tenth of
the year onto one turner
flies one down the line to left
tom moves over to the corner he looks
and it's gone turner gets him again
turner two the pirates one
off tom's glove and into the seats
so two outs the tying run tom moves to
second and it's all up to key brian
[Music]
caught
hayes
over
and the dodgers win it two one
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by jim beam scott
braun jerry harriston jr scott shawn
casey and jp morosi checking out the nl
west standings look at the giants go 38
up 23 down the dodgers in the two spot
just a tick ahead of the san diego
padres it's the big three in the
division and it queues up our first poll
question of the day on youtube you can
weigh in on your smartphone your tablet
your computer where will the dodgers
finish the regular season champs in the
division first nl wildcard second nl
wild card or miss po season a team that
has won eight consecutive division
crowns
jerry you watch this team on a daily
basis i feel like i know what your
answer is going to be
they're going to win the division you
know the giants have played well the
podgers have played well but
those two teams should have separated
themselves from the dodgers while cody
bellinger was hurt for two months while
corey seeger is still hurt the dodger
team has been plagued by injury
and yet they're still in the mix so once
they get healthy i expect them to really
take off in the second half
yeah i kind of i agree with jerry there
i mean i this dodger team i really
believe they're built for the marathon
of 162
and they've had some injuries and
they're still 11 games above 500 so i
think at some point they make a nice run
here
nice two-strike knock from philip evans
to set the table for the pirates in the
home second
but hey it's not just the regular season
it's what this team is capable of in the
postseason they won the world series
last year they're also missing a few
players and bellinger's back but he
missed 46 games mckinstry rios is out
for the season pollock is pretty fresh
off the il
seeger's still hurt lux spent a little
bit of time
off the roster and bets has missed eight
games as well i guess lux technically
just missing some of those days without
a trip to the injured list but there's
bellinger who's missed the most time so
far point being not the healthiest squad
that's opposite field hitting for the
pirates and it's eric gonzalez in
business
and the pirates are going to send home
evans here he comes head first he's in
there we're tied at one on the rbi
double from eric gonzalez
[Applause]
wow gonzalez got a pitch right there was
able to get inside it
just kind of looped it to right field
but evans does a great job of really
getting on his horse and scoring from
first base it looked like it rattled in
the quarter on bets
but man this guy still has a cannon bats
almost came up almost got him at the
plate but you'll see right here gonzales
gets a pitch middle in it does a great
job of kind of getting on top of it and
just shooting at the right field
a really good job of staying inside this
baseball
and really good base running here
understand you know what i'm not going
to take anything for granted even though
mookie betson's in right i'm going to
hustle all around third base to score
[Music]
two hits to start the inning for the
pirates
evan's opposite field single gonzalez
with the double to tie up the game and
now it's kai tom
you know the key here for iris is to
limit the damage even though you get up
a run you gotta run on second base
allen skips away from barnes and moving
up 90 feet is gonzales
[Music]
it's one of those things austin takes
pride in in blocking the baseballs in
the dirt
this breaking ball in the dirt gets away
will be ruled a wild pitch but usually
austin barnes keeps that in front of him
he's such such a great catcher back
there
those secondary pitches are important
for julio you know the fastback command
is important but the curveball and
changeup has to be down
there's one of those secondary pitches
the fastball has been hit
at a really healthy clip by opposing
batters so far this year against julio
and you can see the non-fast balls at
just a buck 27.
that's the curve ball and the change up
and 2-2
is shipped to right betts is gonna grab
it
made it look easy but here comes
gonzalez what a throw from
it's on the money hitting me are you
kidding me
he does it so casually whirl and turtle
a rock at the home for the out
one of the best right fielders i've ever
seen
[Music]
the athleticism from mookie bets is just
it's unbelievable i mean i was thinking
on this ball right here i was like i
don't know if they should send them
because bets has an absolute cannon but
the athleticism right here jerry to come
in and watch the spin he comes in almost
like he's an infielder spin throw right
on the money i mean
unbelievable play
incredible catch
and then the turn around and throw a
dart to home plate on time
incredible play
[Music]
and we're on to mitch keller hey
you guys this guy's one of the best
athletes in all of sports incredible
golfer incredible bowler
he trains as a basketball basketball
basketball player in the offseason
to make sure he has his agility
a complete athlete well he's got it
and make that kevin newman in the eighth
spot first before keller
first outfield assist of the season for
mookie bets out there and right
he just did it because nobody runs on
him
exactly
in case you know this i say it all time
baseball players are the best athletes
they have to be able to do everything
you have to throw like a quarterback you
have to run like a wide receiver
hit 95 to 98
and mookie bets is as good as it gets
and especially you know a guy like
mookie betts i think last year and that
run of the world world series
championship we really got to see his
talents on display with the catches he
was making the throws and and how he was
swinging the bat
first strikeout of the day for urias but
betts is the star of the second baseball
player makes a name for himself every
game in a variety of ways
he's lifted to center field back goes
bellinger on the track leaping and
making the grab at the wall beautifully
done in center field by cody bellinger
lux it's a towering fly ball to right
field sending williams back and keeps
carried out of the yard
[Applause]
driven to right center field he's
already got one tonight make it two
gavin locks with a multi-homer game and
the dodgers lead 7-4 0-1
back to right that is gone
and this game is tied
[Applause]
bellinger hits one way up
[Applause]
chris taylor unloads the bases
on the 14th
you guys
[Music]
it's the mlb game of the week live on
youtube and adding to this unique
viewing experience don't forget to check
out youtube's live game commentary that
features mlb and the team channels today
the pirates and the dodgers and the
select group of youtube creators you can
view the live game commentary on your
computer your mobile device your smart
tv we're gonna keep an eye on the
discussion throughout the broadcast
and we're going to talk to bench coach
for the pirates derek shelton very soon
so we'll take your youtube creator
questions for that movie gaming tv sing
nl west one heck of a division right now
during that discussion and also this
copyrighted telecast is presented by
authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball and may not be
reproduced or re-transmitted in any form
in the accounts and descriptions of this
game may not be disseminated without
express written consents
we hop into the third it's turner
bellinger and beatty do up for the
dodgers and turner fouls off the first
pitch also in that live chat ashley
sanders said wow
leaves the dodgers with the goose egg
during the top of the inning talking
about keller and the pirates
capitalizing during the bottom
they score a run to answer but it could
have been much more mookie betts made a
standout play in right field the catch
and then the throw
like he had been doing it for years so
easily just somebody who's calm
collected jerry
and mookie is also so sure of his
ability that there was just no rush
factor he knew
how the baseball would get there in time
manager dave roberts talks about all the
time that he works on his craft every
single day
let's see justin turner get hit not in
the face jt not in the face
especially if you want a career in tv
after your career of playing baseball
which could be
back
yeah yeah he's one of the best athletes
but he doesn't take anything for granted
he works extremely hard
what's that case left tricep
yeah this hurts this hurts right here
yeah but you know what there's a little
meat on the bone right there you know he
has the elbow pad you take him to the
tricep you're like ah it's not bad it's
gonna be a little tight
so that's why he's got that shield on
the elbow that's where you don't want to
get it where there's no meat
yeah and he works extremely hard in the
weight room and that's why you build
those triceps up
just in case you get hit by a baseball
it doesn't faze you
it's it's
dips
it's preacher curls
that's right
triceps
right
tricep tuesdays
yeah now lay you got you got the beaches
here perfect weather got to have that
beach body i know his wife courtney is
on him about making sure that body stays
tight
great job courtney we know you're
watching
jt looks fine
and
he leads off the third on first now
bellinger has a 3-0 count
now casey 3-0 count if you're the
manager you let him hit here you let him
swing away
heck yeah you kidding me i let bellinger
take a rip right here knowing that
keller this inning looks like he's a
little all over the place he could
groove one right here and belgium can
make this 3-1
he does take a healthy hack and his
manager also predicted a home run for
him so i'm sure he's giving him the
green light today even more so
that's right he's like swing out swing
just keep doing it take some rips 3031
whenever you want
and we talk about dodger nicknames jt
calls him bopper
because of his power
very hip
another big swing from bellinger he
actually has four career homers on 3-0
counts i know for some guys they always
avoid bellinger though
[Music]
can be aggressive
his best season at the plate in 2019 his
first half that year was out of control
and he really got his strikeout to walk
ratio in check that year as well a 2017
rookie of the year payoff pitch we'll do
another
[Applause]
doc was saying before the game he was
talking about bellinger and we were
saying hey what does he need to be
better at and and doc was saying hey he
needs to get on the heater you know we
want to get him back on the heater you
saw him swing through those two
fastballs looked a little long then he
gets that pitch right down the middle
and fouls it off i think keller's gonna
keep attacking him with that heater and
challenge him to hit it
he does he punishes it to right field
it'll drop and turner is trucking for
third and he'll make it there so runners
on the corners to start the inning on
the base hit for bellinger
statcast powered by google cloud and
cody bellinger only has one home run so
far this season but we've seen damage to
different parts of the ballpark from
cody over the past few seasons jerry
yeah he's been outstanding swinging the
bat the biggest thing for him is just
getting back
his swing as far as being on time he's
missed so much time missed two months of
the season so once we start seeing cody
bellinger be more relaxed to the plate
going the other way with two strikes
looking for contact like he just did
right there then the power will come
he has that whippage
through the zone two cody where it's
waiting it's waiting and all of a sudden
you blink and the bat came across
he's got incredible hands back speed
and you know what a lot of people don't
talk about he's an incredible athlete he
can fly
great runner going first to third
scoring from first on a double
really good baseball instincts
you got matt betty up first and third
nobody out you're looking for contact
here
trying to push a run across
80 flew out to left in the first
and that pitch hit him
so it'll load up the bases
wow this is what this is where keller
gets into trouble you know he starts
losing command he hit he had turned into
start to inning
uh he came at bel bellinger and left
that 3-2 breaking ball down the middle i
don't know why he didn't continue with
the fastball then he hits petey here uh
you know to load the bases so
definitely losing a little bit of
command
he hit three batters in his career
and two already in this inning jerry
yeah i mean again command has been an
issue for him in the minor leagues he's
had excellent command
but for whatever reason it hasn't
it hasn't translated to the big leagues
now it's mckin street juicy opportunity
with the bags full of dodgers
if i'm mckinsey right here i'm hunting
the first pitch fastball base is loaded
not great command i'm hunting the heater
right here
there is the fastball
and
then iasonia behind the plate says it
missed and it looked pretty close
zach mccountry went to central michigan
did not hit a home run in college
his first career big league homer inside
the park home run
33rd round selection of that
epic 2016 draft class
by the dodgers
so many hits successful in that draft
for la and mckinstry one of the latest
ones pick number
1001 there's the sac fly line that's the
depth you need
to take the baseball based on
throwing arms out there from tom
reynolds
and evans
got the arm string there i like that 84
86 85
case what was your arm strength at about
97
like 66 67
so that green line would have been in
the infield
i i i took my kids recently to the
kennywood park out here which is a you
know amusement park in pittsburgh and i
got the three balls and lined it up i'm
like all right told my son jake here you
go i and i did it 67 i i hit
past the green line for mckinstry and
that enables turner to score easily the
sac fly puts the dodgers back in front
it's 2-1 off the rbi
and execution is so important sac fly
right there at least get one run with
the bases loaded
uh he's still threatening first and
second one out
[Music]
pittsburgh it's one of my favorite
ballparks in all of baseball
just a beautiful park especially in the
day game
it is beautiful man i i live here and
get a chance to see this park a lot and
it's one of the most special parks you
know in the big leagues with the three
rivers coming and the clementi bridge in
the background
and if you if you've never been to that
ballpark if you're a fan if you love
baseball
make it a point to go visit that stadium
two balls no strikes to gavin lux and
sean i'm jealous you're there
you're the
you and jp half the team
at the park today you can see the bridge
in the background it is picturesque
and it is a gorgeous day out here guys
you should be jealous
gavin lux is from uh
wisconsin as you see
action in the bullpen there for
pittsburgh
gavin looks one of those rare kids grew
up in wisconsin but is a bears fan
and i'm a kid from chicago so you know i
love that
three balls in his strike how does that
happen
boy he's smart you know he he doesn't
listen
he doesn't adhere to the pressures of
the wisconsin and their cheeses
he said you know what i'm going to
follow a team
that that i love that would watch it's
the chicago bears
good for him
he takes the three one
interesting right here guys to watch
keller really losing fastball command
the one pitch he has command off command
right now seems like that little
breaking ball that he's thrown for
strikes
it'll be interesting to see what he does
3-2 here
let's see if he doubles up
two on for la one run in this inning
and that's on the ground nice backhanded
stop by gonzalez he goes to second for
the force
and the fielder's choice puts runners on
the corners so
keller gets the pitch he needs
tough to turn two on that one though
yeah but case you were right it came
through one breaking ball threw a 3-2
breaking ball got the ground ball
it's amazing hitting is not just
obviously bat-to-ball skills you got to
think along with the pitcher
in case you're one of the best at doing
that
i appreciate it jared but i i agree with
what we were saying there is like
as you can see when you can start
eliminating pitches as a hitter and i
and i see that keller's not throwing his
heater all of a sudden i say the only
one he looks comfortable with is really
that breaking ball threw it 3-1 and then
threw it again 3-2
they're gonna let him pitch to barnes
you have second base open and urea is on
deck
is that the move jerry
i think they're seeing if he can get
austin barnes to chase you saw that
first pitch breaking ball now i think
it's a 3-0 uh they may just go elect to
put them on
but they're going to see if austin barks
can get himself out
that's derek shelton's second season
managing the pirates he was the twins
bench coach in 2018
and 2019.
barnes walked first trip to the plate
and there's that breaking ball again
trying to get austin barnes to chase but
austin barnes ain't biting
and you put a lot of pressure on jacob
stallings
to grab those dirt balls
so that bellinger doesn't scurry home
at this point you might as well put them
on
yeah yeah yeah they're not pitching the
barns here no way
just trying to get him to chase like you
said jerry
so why risk it you're right
there it is
let him go to first
the free pass officially issued
intentional walk it'll be urease
and even though austin barnes went to
asu he's very intelligent he knew what
was going on
he said you know what i'm not chase a
pitch
works a walker
help that on base percentage and like
you mentioned earlier jerry
marias can make some loud contact at
times the dodgers have some pretty good
hitting pitchers
yeah they work on it quite a bit at home
they challenge each other you know
getting bumps down but also when you
have an aubry opportunity
put the bat on the ball
he goes after the first pitch it's
fouled off i know there's a solid
competition that goes on i saw bueller
chatting with kershaw the other day
talking about their hitting approach
when you're so good on the mound you
have to think about other things to be
competitive
with they do definitely challenge each
other
uh who's going to get the most hits this
season i know kirsch he had promised me
that he's going to go deep this year
i'll tell you what guys
this is a big victory for keller right
here if he can get he's had so much
traffic he had bases loaded in the
second got out of he really got out of
it and then he's only given up one run
here if he can get out of this one run
that's a that's a win
that's very true you know he's been kind
of dancing around here a lot of traffic
but if you can limit the damage here
you got to feel good about your chances
uh if you're the pittsburgh pirates or
julia
five rbis
this season because you you know he
could swing the bat
second most by a pitcher only to wash
guard you know who's on the il right now
for the braves and you know i had a
grand slam earlier this year to
contribute to some of those ribbies
for keller we just saw his 70th toss of
the day already we're here in the third
so that solid pirates bullpen better get
ready for some long work this afternoon
especially
guys
derek shelton has done an excellent job
managing that bullpen but you're hoping
to get keller at least to five to kind
of help out his bullpen but right now
that pitch counts is climbing
2-2 sent to right and
connects bellinger comes home that'll
score two for the dodgers
make it seven rbis on the season for the
dodgers starter it's four to one
well julio the pride of mexico gets a
breaking ball up in the zone
his idol growing up was big poppy david
ortiz
and he got a breaking ball center cut he
does not miss it great swing head down
on contact through the baseball
two huge two out rbis
and the big problem here guys
keller couldn't throw his fastball for
strikes had to go to the breaking ball
again goes into the uh you know with a
pitcher
it speeds up his bat speed so you know
with keller not having that fastball
command that really hurt him today
maria knocks out the opposing starter
mitch keller gives up the two rbi single
dodgers four pirates one new pitcher
coming in in this third inning
the last half of the ninth inning
it's the new york yankees nine and the
pittsburgh pirates
i was just sitting there thinking about
how in the world we're going to beat
these guys and what's going to happen
here and somebody yelled you're up i
forgot i was up
[Music]
sudden death now last of the ninth nine
to nine as i was walking to the plate
the only thing i could think about was i
gotta hit the ball hard somewhere get on
base and get this thing started i had no
visions of hitting a home run there
trying to hit him
when i hit it
i didn't know for sure if it was going
out so i was running my butt off around
first base and just busting my tail
trying to get to third base but then i
heard the noise of people yelling i
looked down the left field line the
umpires given at this shot
[Music]
[Applause]
then i hit second and i don't think i
touched the ground the rest of the way
home i just floated up
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
as chris stratton warms up on the mound
here at pnc park we do have some
precipitation here in pittsburgh which
makes you wonder
did an inability to grip the ball in
that last at-bat against julio urrias
perhaps affect mitch keller in those key
pitches where this certainly you would
say the the drizzle has intensified not
quite a downpour yet scott but it's
somewhere in the middle we'll keep a
close eye on home plate empire dan
iosonia and the pirates grounds crew as
well thanks jp stay dry for us please
both games before this in the series in
the steel city were delayed by rain
yesterday 70 minutes before first pitch
could start up
and they ended up completing the game
close to midnight about 12 hours later
we're back on the field there's more
precipitation and there's a new pitcher
in the game in the third inning taking
over for mitch keller
who lasted just two in the third it's
chris stratton taking over a 3-2-7 mark
former starter so he can give this team
length already three runs across for the
dodgers in the third fourth total and
the first
came in the first inning from mookie
betts
a home run on pitch number three of the
day his sixth of the season and here we
are a three run game with the rain
coming down a little bit harder now in
the berg
[Applause]
and stratton quickly ahead 0-2
on mookie betts
mookie 2 really good at bats so far this
game the lead off homer
and the walk
yeah third inning already third at bat
for bets
and he lays off that pitch up
stratton last pitch on tuesday gave up
two runs in two innings
four seam fastball curve ball slider
and some changeups in the repertoire
yeah first two pitches he kind of came
with the off speed try to get him to
chase then he comes with then he comes
with two heaters
trying to put him away but mookie's not
fighting on that
he went around
and stratton struck him out
so he comes in picks up the one out he
needs and strands a couple base runner
but the dodgers attack with three they
knock out the starter mid three dodgers
up 4-1
and another one of those delayed steals
you got the tag on and he's out yeah
that's a tough play by cool wow reynolds
switch hitter batting left one two is
blasted to right deep toward the wall
god home run for brian reynolds
and reynolds with his eighth run of the
year ties the game at one
this is hard to center field setting
marty back to the track to the wall
clear the deck with a cannonball
the kid keep ryan hayes
you've got to be kidding me johnny
and now they're loaded for stallings
line drive to left field this is going
to get down
jacob stallings the cheetah just doubled
in one
two
and three runs
how about that
fly ball center field that'll do it walk
it off cheetah you're hungry go eat and
raise the jolly roger
what a grinded out win in 12 for the
battle in bucks an 8-7 victory the
pirates win the first three games of
this four game series against the
marlins
last of the third in pittsburgh dodgers
up 4-1 our first poll question of the
day on youtube is complete we're looking
for where the dodgers are going to
finish up the regular season in the
division and dodgers fans are watching
and they're weighing in big jerry 64 say
they're winning the west again for a
ninth consecutive year
yeah a lot of dodger fans are watching
but
the poll there
the six percent missed the postseason
i'm gonna bet six percent of those are
should be giants fans
i think you're probably right the giants
fans definitely pulled in and they said
no they're not gonna make it only six
percent of them
you can do some good trolling here with
this poll question anyone that's not a
fan
of the dodgers dominance
over the past decade and we've seen them
off to work so far today in a big way
a home run from bets a patient third
inning
to work through mitch keller's
ineffectiveness with his command and
ultimately knocking him out of the game
bets also made an elite play in right
field the catch and preventing the sac
fly from going down earlier and that's
why the pirates just have won so far
this afternoon philip evans scored on a
double from eric gonzalez
now we're in the third back to julio
urias after a long layoff between
innings
mlb originals season two is live on
youtube with new episodes every week see
your favorite players and learn more
about the game you love on youtube.com
mlb
9-1-2 in the order for pittsburgh chris
stratton just took over
for one out in the last half inning and
now he will be at the plate he only took
over as a relief pitcher full-time
last year before that he had been a
starter so there are 63 career at-bats
to his name
and if you're the pitcher julio you're
looking for that shutdown inning you
just finished scoring some runs and you
just got a huge hit
you got to throw strikes and get your
team back in the dugout
it's something marias has done very well
so far this season compared to the
beginning of his career in his first 38
starts in the big leagues
through 2020
he averaged four and two-thirds innings
per start this year he's a bit over six
innings per outing
and he's got experience on that yeah you
can't teach experience on that as far as
going out there and learning how to fill
up the strike zone pitching the big
leagues you could tell urease
especially this this year is really
filling up the strike zone uh maximizing
his pitch count and thus he's going
later in the games
second strikeout today for rheus now top
of the order adam frazier most hits in
baseball and
he will
bat with haze on deck
frazier is miked up today too so some
good sound coming soon from adam
on base percentage at 390 so far this
season
potentially could be
a trade candidate
about a month from now when we get close
to the july 31st deadline
we'll talk to jp about that soon
he popped out to first base first time
up this time scorches one down the line
this is what adam frazier does best
he'll hustle the second with a one-out
double
all right adam we saw what you can do
with the bat what about with the mouth
[Music]
oh yeah
go go go go up martin
doing right
how you doing there good yeah have a
good one
that change up he threw
literally would have hit me in the mouth
i didn't swing and hit it
it feels like case the kind of guy who
is talking baseball 24 7. it's one of
those like how are you how's the family
oh well you know yesterday did you see
that playing right as we see his 22nd
double the season is best in baseball
he's got that feel
no this guy's a baseball rat he loves it
24-7 seven days a week and you could
tell just by the way he plays a game how
hard he plays the game uh just how he
gets after in a bat how he plays in the
field you saw him before the game when
he's mic'd up saying let's go let's go
let's go so uh you know i love it and
when you see this picture right here
that's what he's been so good on look
how short and quick it is that ball is
black in the inner half of the plate
lefty on left he does a great job of
being short and quick gets the barrel on
the ball and shoots it down the right
field line
you know scotty you're talking about
possible trade options out there for
frasier
and he's a guy that could be a candidate
for let's say the yankees
uh that have struggled with putting the
bat on the ball he's a left-handed
hitter
he's just a really good overall ball
player scrappy any team would be lucky
to have him
keep brian hayes on the one two it's
back to rius and they've got fraser
caught
he's racing around tag applied
and that's mckinstry
recording out number two hayes heads to
first
you know sometimes i joke about pitchers
being kickers but urease incredible
after you saw him handle the bat how
about the glove right there easy snag
right there get over to zach who applies
the tag
nicely executed
so now reynolds steps up with haze on
first
and we're about to see pitch number 40
from julio this afternoon
[Music]
starting to see more and more change-ups
breaking balls first pitch attacking
these pirates hitters
trying to get it over
dave roberts told us
the dodgers would love to see even more
of that curveball and change up for
maria's
there's the slurve
that's almost unhittable i mean it's a
backdoor
curveball that's on the you know off the
plate and then it's just catching the
corner that's a
if he could throw that there you know
keep throwing it there that's that's a
tough pitch for the pirate partners to
hit
and that riding fastball right after
that breaking ball because you got to
protect after that breaking ball now
you're just 1-0 you're down in the count
one two
and he establishes that threat of high
velocity
then he has two excellent secondary
weapons
on the one two
goes with the curve reynolds hammers it
deep left
beady gives it a look
and it's gone
brian reynolds for two
number 10 on the season and the pirates
make this a one-run game
the power stroke for brian reynolds has
really been there these last few weeks
guys he's really been driving the ball
in the park driving in a lot of runs he
gets a pitch right here from from aries
just out over the plate really a hanging
breaking ball renters does a great job
of staying on it driving through it and
getting it out of the park
you'll see right here watch this hanger
i mean it comes right into the nitro
zone middle in gives reynolds his eyes
his eyes probably light up he waits on
it drops the head on it
now stallings pop that one up
and
bets will jog in
and keep going to the dugout but two for
the pirates to inch back
brian reynolds thinking big it's 4-3
dodgers through three
jim lewin was it was always honest
and if he hurt your feelings in the
process of telling you something honest
he didn't care because he thought it was
in your best interest
he just had very little
uh tolerance for not playing hard he
might not be able to get it bust your
ass back there you never know he's like
get yourself ready to play if you're not
i'll find someone else that will
and that was a strict message
yeah he's old school
old school means you do things the right
way
jim leglen is
i think the deepest most knowledgeable
baseball man
that i know is still living
jim was not just smart
but he was gutsy he was going to take
the best shot to win
did not care about being second guess
i did my job
and i can look in the mirror
jim liam never takes credit for a win
and always takes blame for a loss and as
a player you can really appreciate that
the game belongs to your players
and they're the guys that want it
i didn't have a lot to do with it i
think he's one of the most amazing
leaders
in any sport of our time
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
pirates trail by a run as we enter the
fourth bench coach don kelly played nine
seasons in the bigs and you can see his
post-playing career part of the tigers
astros and now the bench coach of the
pittsburgh pirates for a second season
also a close friend of sean casey and
youtube creators will take some of your
questions for the pirates bench coach
who joins us right now our jim beam
interview in the dugout
don good afternoon and let's start with
what you just saw from brian reynolds
movie gaming tv in the live commentary
section said this has been a fun one so
far great swing by reynolds do you agree
hey
can you hear me guys yeah we got you
done uh-oh okay awesome
um yeah it was a great swing by uh brian
there and uh he's he's tremendous uh
gives good at bats every night and uh
does a great job
uh-oh
oh we got you don i think i think
shawn's okay cool he's struggling so
i'll keep going with you hey let's
let's move to mitch keller for a moment
i know last time out
he was lifted early because of some heat
issues that led to some stomach problems
what did you see from him today coming
off the covet il
yeah he was uh he was doing well there
early ran into some trouble there in the
third inning and um you know just
command was a little bit spotty but you
know stuff was really good there early
in the game
max muncie facing a 1-1 and it's one and
two
hey tell us a little bit tony oh case
you're back
yeah okay so what's up brother hey
donny what's up brother hey hey i heard
how you do tell us what happened
dick good man tell us what happened in
your office today rebelo told me
something like you had a flood in your
office or something this morning
yeah i i still think he set that up we
had a little leak but uh
rebs picked me up got my computer out of
the way
it's great dude
hey dk can you talk a little bit about
frasier about just how good he's been
for you guys and and and just you see
him every day like what is what do you
see every day from frasier that makes
him so good
he's a baseball player man he shows up
every day you see the play that he makes
there defensively brings it every day
offensively he's the table setter for us
i mean just the bats that he puts on
the energy and consistency that he
brings every single day
you know he can't say enough great
positive things about the guy
so after muncie rolled into the shift
it's justin turner who's reached base
twice so far today we're talking to
pirates bench coach don kelly this hat
finning and taking some questions from
the youtube creators
five point vids with this good one is
making it as a bench coach in mlb
similar to trying to make it as a player
[Music]
oh
that's a really really great question um
yeah it's uh it's
any job in major league baseball is
awesome you know playing coaching it's
just great you guys see it out here
getting to compete against these guys
the dodgers and all the other teams some
you know and especially to be able to be
the bench coach in my hometown has been
really awesome
all right next up from movie gaming tv
yo don which coach had the biggest
impact on you throughout your playing
career
oh really great question there's so many
um you know once i got to the big
leagues jim leland was i was the biggest
guy for me i learned a ton from him in
detroit and even now coaching getting
into the coaching ranks being able to
call him and just have such a great
resource to bounce ideas off of
dk
i want to i got a question for you just
as far as appreciating the game
uh the play by mookie betsy uh a couple
innings ago where he comes in spin
throws against rodriguez at the play man
what'd you think of that
wow unbelievable isn't it i mean just to
be able to come in make a
shoestring type catch like that have the
body control arm strength i mean just
the
the whole package there getting uh
getting the throw off to home plate and
uh play great play by barnes too to be
able to pick that and put the tag on
stack has powered by google cloud
look at bats with the arm and does it
so smoothly justin turner takes one high
and tight
full count don kelly with us right now
here in the fourth dodgers up a run the
mlb channel
asking a question about
coaching life don how is being a younger
coach helped you deal with the players
i'm sure you love
the uh the line mixed in there younger
coach that always feels good to hear
right
it does hey i'll tell you it's it's been
great you know just getting off the from
playing myself and to be be able to
relate to these guys
understand what they're going through on
a daily basis
and just the challenges of playing major
league baseball the pressure that they
put on themselves such a tough game to
play but to be able to relate to that in
in this
has been has been great getting into the
coaching ranks and being able to do that
dk what about shelty man what about what
about him how has he made it easy for
you as the bench coach you know in that
role for you
great question he's been awesome i mean
he's uh
he's so consistent he's funny he's he's
detailed he's organized and really
him having done the job before has
helped me out a ton and being able to
understand you know being a bench coach
and and really the conversations and the
communication is tremendous being able
to you know
he lets me know things that he needs and
uh just just a tremendous guy don thanks
for the time we'll let you get back to
work new pitcher coming in in case you
could say goodbye to your buddy
thanks because
i'll catch up with you
yeah thanks guys
see ya that's don kelly bench coach for
the pirates who bring in their third
pitcher today jason shreve will take
over for chris stratton dodgers
threatening in the fourth up by a run
it's time for ask the dodgers where the
players answer some questions submitted
by the fans
what's up guys my name is uh marsha
whitmer i live in charleston south
carolina and my favorite player is
clayton kershaw because i am a
left-handed pitcher myself
and i just had one question for him um
so take me through
like your pre-game routine like what
throwing stretching and when it comes
like your bullpen and stuff i just
wanted to know about that thanks guys
hey marshall thanks for the question man
i mean i think uh my routine is pretty
uh like down to the minute i don't want
to bore you with everything that i do
but i think the biggest key for all of
that is just having a routine that you
stay consistent with so whatever you
feel confident in whatever you feel like
gets you ready to pitch the best the
most important thing is just trying to
be consistent so that way you know when
you do pitch if you happen to pitch well
or if it's bad you can't blame it on
something else it's uh you're always
prepared in the moment i'm a little bit
excessive i'd probably say i think my
teammates would probably say that as
well as far as my routine but it makes
me feel like i'm ready to pitch so i do
it
thanks for watching ask the dodgers
[Music]
[Music]
step up to the plate compete online and
crush dingers in mlb home run derby
download on the app store and google
play store for free today
pnc park in pittsburgh pennsylvania a
good one so far this afternoon jason
shreve the third pitcher of the day for
the pirates trying to salvage a game in
this three-game set against the
defending champion los angeles dodgers
shreve off to a nice start so far this
season and we saw the splitter there and
he's using it a career-high 43 percent
of the time and it produces a swing and
miss from cody bellinger in the fourth
with justin turner on first scott braun
shawn casey jerry harriston jr and j.p
morozzi
it's four seam case or it's splitter
from the pirate's lefty
and ballinger fouled it back
[Music]
let's go to jp for a moment for a little
more on chase and shree jp
well scott this time of year we love
talking about the draft so how about
this college baseball jason shreve was a
teammate at the college of southern
nevada of
bryce harper they actually met when they
were 16 years old became college
teammates and bryce was his catcher
at southern nevada
[Applause]
this season on a minor league
good to see him join uh bryce harper in
the big leagues college teammates
every time i think of bryce harper i
remember
sports illustrated cover at 16.
bellinger stays alive i don't think many
people realize also jerry that
harper's playing catcher at first
and if anything i know he's talked about
the fact that it just helped to expand
his baseball knowledge understanding of
the game and understanding of how
pitchers work
that's a great point scott because
as a catcher you're in every pitch
you're calling the games and you're
gaining the trust
of your pitching staff so it definitely
helped bryce's uh development as a
player
you just saw the pirates infielders
bunched up to the right side that's
where bellinger goes and that's going to
set up a double play executed by the
pirates defense
[Applause]
so chase and shreve comes in gets the
ground ball they need to escape the
fourth here it is again
gonzalez is that middle infielder that's
playing first base this is a great play
by him
backhand toss to second bring it all
back pirates trail by just to run we'll
head to their part of the fourth on
youtube
america in 1981 was a place and time
when the pages in a folk tale turned at
the right pace faster than the evening
paper slower than a tweet with space to
soak in the wonder in every chapter it's
a fairy tale so preposterous dodger fans
dare not open their eyes el nino is
fernando valenzuela
fernando mania was more than one of the
best stretches of pitching in baseball
history
[Music]
sold out tonight
valenzuela's pitching
it was an experience without compare
before or in the four decades since
a singular story that becomes more
transcendent each time we tell it
1981 will be the year of fernando
valenzuela
the left-hander from echo aquila mexico
captivated los angeles and ultimately
the country with his extraordinary
pitching
one-of-a-kind wind-up
and unassuming way
and of course here today a lot of folks
have come in just to see the mexican
phenom fernando valenzuela and why not
he's the hottest subject in baseball
perhaps such early season hysteria could
only be born in hollywood what else can
be said but
viva valenzuela
watching mookie betz's brilliant catch
earlier today a flashback to last
october series turning plays that mookie
had made up against the wall the one
also coming in as shoe top grab to
double off a run i was about to score
for the atlanta braves in that game
incredible game changing defense scott
and i got to tell you being here at
pittsburgh watching it live goosebumps
because i'm watching him do it all in
front of the clementi wall i see the
clementi bridge in the background you
have to think about the great one when
mookie betts makes that shoot top catch
unleashes that beautiful throw scott it
is baseball poetry as clemente once
authored in this city of course that
world series 50 years ago
and that's golfed into left center it's
a base hit
as the pirates start off the fourth
inning with phillip evans single thanks
jp
and
in right field
the dimensions are also in honor of
roberto clemente that wall in right is
21 feet tall
21 in this city guys i've seen
everything
especially because of clemente and that
21 foot wall right field was one of the
you know when this park was built in
2001 that was a big deal that they they
made that feat that that wall 21 feet
high for clemente
in case i've seen a lot of great right
fielders i've played with
uh quite a few of them you know we also
puke was a really good right fielder but
the best right fielder i've ever seen in
my eyes as a player
uh has been mookie betts he comes in on
ballsy accuracy with his arm
that's a nice backhanded stop by
mckinstry the throw on a hop nicely
picked up by muncie for the out
zach mckesson making that play look easy
one hop there to max muncie kind of
helping his first baseman out in case
she knows it know this as a first base
but if you're gonna throw it on a hop
make sure it's a long hop
really good play by max
yeah really good play by muncie right
here this is a tough pick it's right on
the lip right in front of lip there's
nothing right there he and it kind of
kicks up on him he does a great job of
snagging that
evans moves up
i always say guys you know you don't see
the you don't see any plays in the
highlight reel if the first place is not
picking it you know what i'm saying
i'm always shouting guys i have a good
first baseman that's right
from you know freddie freeman anthony
rizzo paul goldschmidt muncie did a heck
of a job right there
and that is a really tough baseball to
pick up and
first baseman like you sean make it look
so simple
that's right scott don't you forget that
pal they go they don't get enough
appreciation you just think you can
throw anyone over there it's not true
that's why muncie's so valuable he plays
third he plays second but then you put
him at first base and he's and he plays
a great first base too
you know first basemans are kind of like
the offensive line you know they don't
get enough
enough love
uh helping the running back we're
helping the quarterback you know protect
that quarterback and max muncie picking
up his teammate right there
important piece to the infield one out
one on kai tom breaks his bat and that's
weakly to short lux is gonna have to
hurry his throw is there
[Applause]
look at this infield defense go
that's a great play right there by gavin
lux a little jam shot there
has to throw it on the run gotta hurry
make a strong accurate throw
great play
[Music]
the game is so fast watch this transfer
that transfer right there man these big
league shortstop guys that can do that
and the timing to know man i'm going to
get them by by a half an inch right here
if i get rid of it right now the
footwork and the timing of that throw
was unbelievable by lux
[Music]
that brings us to kevin newman first
pitch strike fastball in there from
maurice
it's a big at-bat here for newman he got
two outs running on third base down a
run
big moment in the ball game
lowest ops in baseball so far this year
sends that one to right
bets looking and finding it
and
he makes the catch
to end the inning how about the defense
from the dodgers in the fourth mckinstry
lux
and betts is always there
for a scoreless fourth from maurice
and so from the brink of elimination the
pirates got set for a game seven in
baltimore
chock full of confidence
i had just gotten traded from the
steelers to the 49ers so i'm out in san
francisco
but i've watched these guys all summer
and how they're playing i said they are
going to win this i just know it
it was destiny
the big man
the pirates they're a happy
it is now 2-1 pittsburgh
at 79
we weren't going to be denied at all
pittsburgh aren't just a little bit away
from winning another world championship
kelly hits it in the air to center field
mourinho pouring toward right center
makes the catch pittsburgh wins it
and so this team with its remarkable
comeback capacity proved itself all over
again
[Applause]
pittsburgh pirates 1979 world champions
that was your first one it was wonderful
huh yeah it was wow played with some
great guys i definitely wanted this is
something i wanted all my life
[Music]
we're up to the fifth in pittsburgh the
rain has disappeared for now and we
appreciate you hanging out with us today
on youtube as we check out the top draft
prospects the draft is coming up about a
month away
the 2021 top players available you're
looking at the list which is very
important
for the pittsburgh pirates they had the
worst record in baseball last year that
means they get to select from that list
we'll keep it simple for you with our
second youtube poll question of the day
who would you choose with number one are
you going seasoned college player
or high school prospects
you know what i'm choosing first the the
best player available i don't care if
it's a season college player or a high
school prospect you know there's a lot
of great high school prospects out there
and look at our draft cody bellinger
came out of high school corey seger came
out of high school so i'm looking best
player available
that's the smart call
beatty pops out into shallow left center
jp what do you think
well scott this to me is the year of the
prep shortstop we have a number of the
top players in the country for the draft
are high school shortstops marcelo mayer
i would say for me is the one that our
colleagues at mlb pipeline have going to
the pirates so i would affirm that mayor
is the right choice for pittsburgh but
also
jordan lawler part of the conversation
brady house a prep shortstop and of
course the co-aces at vanderbilt jack
leiter kumar rocker henry davis over at
louisville of course the dodgers had a
pretty good catcher from louisville
themselves in will smith behind the
point so henry davis is getting some
buzz at the number one overall pick as
well so a lot of great choices we even
heard derek shelton saying as the draft
gets closer of course this year for the
first time happening at the all-star
game in denver derek shelton he'll
probably start looking at some scouting
video as well the future of the
pittsburgh pirates
the dodgers for years now are picking
in the back of the first round
but they've done well they're shelton
pittsburgh
will have
really a tough choice at number one it's
not like it's between two guys this year
it's between about five or six like
we're showing you
well the dodgers just find gems in the
33rd round in 2016 like mckinstry who
swings through the 1-1
i think one thing with this pick guys
with the pirates
is that they really gotta they really
gotta
they really got a hit on this one the
pirates they can't afford having this
first pick with so many talented players
they really got a hit with that first
pick this in this draft
i completely agree with sean right there
you have to be able to hit on the first
pick
of the draft if you're the pittsburgh
pirates you cannot afford especially
when you're trying to build that farm
system up you can't afford to make
mistakes so
they're going to do their homework and
they're going to select the best player
that not only fits their system but the
best player available
they had the number one pick
back in 2011
and they hit on the pick
it was garrett cole but his best
baseball
has been with the astros and now with
the yankees
whose goal in 2011.
mckinstry
to a leaping gonzalez he plays a nice
first base
two outs in the fifth ben charrington is
the gm of the pittsburgh pirates
and this offseason alone he picked up 14
prospects in deals for joe musgrove
jameson tyone
and josh bell there's the one for
starling marte last year at the trade
deadline with the marlins as well so
some serious quantity to fill up the
farm system and that's something ben
said they desperately needed to build
things back up and get ready for the
future sean
well well ben charington's got a track
record guys he built up a lot of that a
lot of the a lot of that farm system in
boston before he was let go there uh one
of the ones that one won the world
championship and he was there as the gm
too um but yeah the pirates hey
they knew when they when they when they
got rid of a guy like josh bell and they
had to move some of the starling marty's
of the world they knew that it's a
rebuild and uh ben sheridan has done a
great job at getting some guys in the
system right now that could come up and
help help in the big leagues in the
future
and we talked to manager derek shelton
earlier today and it's it's a tough
process you know you're trying to win
now as a big league club but you're also
trying to develop guys and part of that
development is making sure you have
enough guys in the minor leagues so when
they're ready at 21 22 years of age
they're ready to compete at the big
league level
it's a great inning from jason shree
three up three down in the fifth pirates
down a run their turn to bat
[Music]
welcome back to three con park at
candlestick point here in san francisco
as we head to the bottom of the ninth
inning and kevin brown is just three
outs away
and the bottom of the order coming up
for san francisco
9-0 in the marlins with a big lead but
right now the story is right-handed
kevin brown
there's a chopper hit behind first base
and now kevin brown is just two outs
away
without the
and now brown is only one out of the way
and so now brown is just one strike away
from
what would be the second no-hitter in
marlin
it's a history
[Applause]
and kevin brown is being mobbed
the second no-hitter in marlin history
and on this tuesday afternoon in san
francisco a total crown out as the
giants do not get a hit
[Applause]
[Music]
first
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i saw you try to go for
construction that was good
yeah
he was on the dirt
and then i ran for him he got on the
ground
[Music]
kill baby
we do this every week on youtube and
sometimes the guys are joking around
they're giving us really funny content
with adam frazier you are getting
baseball strategy
trying to create a little obstruction
there jerry it sounded like
yeah he certainly was you know it's one
of those things where it's a tough play
a tough read for uh the second base
receiving a second base runner now
ball's hit back to julio
now still count as one one but frazier
you kind of took an educated gamble
there but you got to credit yurious
right there able to make a great play
and then run him back
uh
and set up get him in that rundown so
frazier a really good player really
heads up player just one of those things
where he took a educated gamble it just
didn't work out
ball in two strikes to pinch hitter ben
gamel
and also
the way that adam frazier just so
seamlessly can play a variety of
positions
contact hitting machine
he's going to be we're just talking
about
you know scotty we're you're just
talking about the draft and you know if
somebody as casey does too so many
friends in the game of baseball they're
looking for guys like frazier can play a
variety of positions and contact is king
in their repertoire looking for that
contact hitters uh sure everybody loves
guys hit the ball at ballpark but more
so than not you want those guys that
have great bat-to-ball skills and
frasier is definitely one of those guys
there he is
on deck after gamble
jerry you know what it's like to learn a
variety of positions and the challenges
of playing those positions so well and
you've gotten to see the progression of
chris taylor on the dodgers and how much
better he's become defensively because
you're not just learning your craft at
one spot as a professional you have to
be able to pick up a different glove in
a different position every day what's
that like
well it's not an easy process but chris
taylor and frazier these guys learn how
to do this
at the big league level you know
sometimes you guys learn to play a
variety of positions in their leagues
some in college but a guy like chris
taylor he never really played outfield
until he got to the big league so he
really worked hard uh not just being an
average outfielder now he's a plus
defender out there he's always had that
great arm and i've always been a firm
believer if you're a really good athlete
and you can play shortstop you can go
play a variety of positions
maria spots one for strike three
in his third cab of the day
dodger defense
they take a lot of pride in run
prevention
and we've seen examples today like
mookie bets in right and zach mckinstry
at second base who can also play a
number of different positions gavin lux
does an excellent job at shortstop and
vets can run down just about anything
we just saw mookie bets right there
mookie betts i say all the time he's the
ultimate super utility guy because he
can play the infield too he's played
second base he came up as a second
baseman but because he's got such a
great arm they put him in right field
you're always
looking to draft guys that are great
athletes
pop out and then a double in the third
inning for frasier
and now another o2 pitch coming up
one thing that has separated julio reyes
this season in past seasons the ability
to put guys away with the off speeds
pitch he's got 02 to frazier here
looking to put him away with a couple
pitches here
there's a slider in the dirt
it registers as a curve ball but i hear
dodgers
brass officially call it a slurve which
is just not an option on the statcast
selection but
just to give you an idea of what we're
describing and this time maria's with
the fastball too high
he wanted to make sure frazier wasn't
looking out there to probably set up
this very next pitch
got away from a little bit
2-2 that's a breaking ball and that's
for bellinger
two gone
okay with adam frazier just retired
which is not easy to do jp we wonder
will he still be in that uniform a month
from now
my belief is the answer is no i think
jerry has pointed out that the yankees
are a tremendous fit the yankees
surprisingly
are struggling to hit from the left side
left-handed power is what the yankees
are known for but frazier could really
help them with more contact the
versatility i would also say a couple
teams within the nl central both the
brewers and the cardinals both have some
needs at second base and jerry refresh
my memory back in 2009 when the yankees
won the world series did they go to an
nl central team and find someone who was
great playing all around the diamond and
making contact who helped them win a
world series that year jerry
uh they did you know they had a team
that was full of talent but they were
looking for a guy to kind of lead that
group with derek jeter mariano rivera
alex rodriguez so they traded for this
guy from cincinnati who could play a
variety of positions they go on to win
the world series they don't resign him
and they haven't won a world series
since
[Music]
oh
touche that's good
i'm gonna guess that's not the first
time you've used that but i love it
jerry hairston jr world series ring
yankees haven't won since 2009
i'm gonna get a text i know in the next
couple of minutes from a couple of guys
it's so good
still one and two to keep ryan hayes
[Music]
but in honesty teams always can use a
guy like a fraser you can lead him off
he's got speed very good defensively we
mention it again contact especially
nowadays is king you're looking for guys
like frazier
big swing and a miss from his swinging
out of his shoes fourth strikeout for
urias
a one two three fifth fraser and the
pirates trail by a run through five
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
that was unbelievable
grounded to third gonzalez smooth the
silk over there and there craig will
come off the back
well actually shouldn't be laughing
that's it's not a bad idea
oh my goodness and then there's nobody
at first no way
oh
that is unbelievable never seen that
before
javier baez just stole a run for his
cubs
youtube pitch is reach for a little
pop-up
[Applause]
heck of a play here folks well not only
did he make the play but he made the
play while holding his cell phone and
videotaping himself
all at the same time so not only does he
leave with a souvenir but he leaves with
a toast as well
[Music]
top six dodgers up a run and each week
this season we're focusing on a youtube
content creator featured in our live
game commentary section our creator
spotlight shines on cowboy jeff you can
watch this dodger fan create videos
about gaming and sports his goal is to
share his love of baseball with everyone
about two and a half million views on
his videos close to 30 000 subscribers
he only launched his channel two years
back so
kids youtube creator dreams can come
true
he also is from dodger films a big time
youtube channel so hello cowboy jeff
give us a hello in the live chat and
we'll hit you back here on the broadcast
so let's finish up our second poll
question of the day who would you choose
with the number one pick in the draft
are you going seasoned college player or
high school prospect and about
two-thirds of the audience goes with the
seasoned college player and
case i think we're of course
generalizing with a question like this
but it plays to the fact that hopefully
it's a guy that your organization can
see sooner in the big leagues and guess
what fans don't like to wait
things especially nowadays scotty is
like you know they want to see guys
there fast and you know when you look at
this draft there's so many good players
at the top
and uh you know a lot of good a lot of
good high school short stops and a lot
of good college arms so at the end of
the day you know i think if the pirates
look at it maybe it's that college that
that high school shortstop a guy like a
like a derek jeter that could be a
franchise type guy
i agree with sean right there i mean
just get the best player you can get you
know looking at the dodgers draft i
mentioned earlier cody bellinger corey
seeger clayton kershaw they were all
high school guys
what if they would have taken a chance
on a college guy and not got a chance to
draft those three studs so again you can
get college studs as well like a mark
prior who a a huge standout strasberg
pitched at san diego state was a stud so
just make sure the guy you're picking is
a stud yeah high upside is the goal like
garrett cole for the pirates out of ucla
last time they selected number one
and don't forget brony garrett cole has
some good years here in pittsburgh the
one year he was he was uh third in sa
young
so i mean he you know he had some good
years but you know at the end of the day
they weren't going to be able to sign
them long term
dwayne underwood jr into the sixth
inning and he walks austin barnes
third walk of the day for barnes took
that 3-2 pitch he's on first in the
sixth and we're going to jp at the
ballpark
well scott in 2006 i was actually a
young man believe it or not and i was
covering the tigers for the free press
and they traded for sean casey i was
pretty excited about that because as we
all know case is one of the great people
in baseball so case goes on he bats 5 29
in the world series against the
cardinals that year and what i want to
ask sean is this
when you finally got there and faced the
cardinals a team you knew so well from
this division
how much did that help how much of a
factor is it still switching leagues
even as we have interleague play we have
all that scouting information how much
of an adjustment period was there for
uno six and is there now for players
still to this day
oh jp that's a great question i know for
me when i went over to the american
league you know with the tigers in the
middle of a penta race which was awesome
um you know it was a little bit of
adjustment facing those teams that i
hadn't seen all the time but then when i
went to the world series and we're
facing st louis it was like man it just
it just felt so good um to be in a place
that you know in a city and against a
team that i played so much against my
career so i think it definitely helped
me in the world series being familiar
with them
see julio heading back to
the batter's box trying to get that bunk
down we talked we saw him earlier get
the bunt down then had a huge two out
two rbi single early in this ball game
trying to execute
he is the
pitching leader
in rbis
at the plate this season
jumping past wascar you know of the
braves
that's bunted foul and arias is out
[Music]
and you know he's disappointed in
himself right there trying to help the
cause here you know you have mookie beth
behind him he only got a one-run lead
right now
very disappointed himself usually he
gets the bun down handles it back
and now underwood against mookie betts
homer walk strikeout
those three at bats in the first three
innings for la
you know it's been a a joy to watch and
see mookie
betts play on an everyday basis i knew
he was a great player with the red sox
but to see him
his athleticism on display on defense
and on offense has been special just one
of the
best
skilled baseball players i've ever seen
jerry i think that's the biggest thing
about mookie is that you know he hasn't
gone off to a super hot start
offensively but you have the
appreciation to see this guy
run the bases
make plays defensively use the king of
an arm i mean i think that's what makes
him uh one of the best players in
baseball is that he he can beat you in
so many different ways
and as we check out his last four
seasons the barrel percentage which is
good and the hard hit percentage which
you want is down this year and it's
trickled down the last few seasons from
the career high in 2018 as the al mvp
and you wonder also jerry this year if
some of that had to do with the lower
back tightness he was dealing with in
the month of april i know he missed a
little bit of time so i wonder if we'll
eventually have splits on those numbers
where the second half of the season
looks more powerful from
a strong man
yeah you're right you know he was
dealing with that lower back uh whether
it's stiffness tightness or that lower
back issue and he also had a right
shoulder injury that he really didn't
disclose to a lot of people but he
understood the importance of having
himself in that lineup because you're
missing corey seeger miss cody bellinger
for two months he needs to be in that
lineup he's as tough as it gets
and even when the bat he's a throwback
guy yeah
yeah yeah scott he's that throwback guy
that says you know what even if i have
some nagging injuries i'm going to play
you know my team needs me it's that cal
ripken junior approach
i'm going to be banged up a lot of
people thought oh cal ripken jr he never
got hurt cal was hurt all the time
he just went out there every single day
for his team
and that's what mookie beck's
that's how he approaches the game even
though i'm banged up i'm gonna be out
there
well it's just always something
from mookie and we saw that last year in
the postseason in 2020 the dodgers
invested big first off in trading for
him from the red sox and then extending
him for 12 more seasons so since the
start of 2020 he has the highest war
among position players wins above
replacement comprehensive stat to kind
of try and sum up his batting his base
running his elite fielding in right
fields
this one hanging up there for the second
baseman frazier to haul in for out
number two
well frazier made that look easy that is
not an easy play there you got the right
fielder to deal with
able to make that basket catch there
really good jump on the baseball over
the shoulder catch calls out the right
feeler i got it makes the play look easy
here comes max muncie the
manager dave roberts calls them the mvp
so far this season having a great
offensive year
yeah when you look at the stats it's a
fair point
and
max bringing the power
always the patience
he's had some monster seasons with la
2019 35 homers
98 runs driven in
and takes the 0-1-2 out pitch and
that'll get cleaned up
and sit down the side one left stranded
dodgers still hanging on to that one run
lead back to julio marias in the sixth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hits one deep to left field
and this one is gone
for jacob stallings what is happening
that is
[Applause]
totally awesome
that's hit hard to center field
oh great try but no chance for daza so
stallings into second base the cheetah
wants three
look at him go and he's got a trip trip
triple they love the cheetah
[Applause]
line drive to left field this is gonna
get down
jacob stallings the cheetah just doubled
in one
two
and three runs
how about that
and the bucks lead it now five to three
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
we're in the home sixth checking out
some of the prettiest parks most
historic ballparks
in the country
from fenway
to oracle in san francisco what a view
with the water
pittsburgh is up there for sure also
thanks to some water out there beyond
the outfields the allegheny and then
this water is man-made in chase field
but still awesome to drop a baseball in
there if you go long so our next poll on
youtube where would you most want your
home run to land
monster seats mccovey cove allegheny
or the pool in phoenix oh i like this
one jerry where do you want your home
run ball to land
well i'm so glad that you asked me first
there uh
you know monster sheets i got a chance
to
uh a chance to visit the monster seats
uh when i was in the orioles i took
martinez way back uh into the monster
seat so they've already done that
uh how about the pool you know i was on
the 2012 dodgers when we clinched there
in arizona we had a nice little pool
party there so i wouldn't mind uh
hitting a home run in that pool i always
have been a fan of pool parts
well i was fortunate jared i hit one in
the pool in arizona so i got that in my
books
i hit the first home run ever at pnc
park so i consider that in my books it
wasn't in the river but it's the first
one it's even bigger
and
i never i think mccovey cove i always
wanted to hit one in mccovey cove and
never did i wanted to see someone out
there like scott braun paddle in his
kayak to go get the ball so mccovey cove
would be the big one for me
those are great answers and i didn't
know you hit the first home run at pnc
ballpark outstanding congratulations
there case i never want to hit one in
mccovey cove because i've always have
been afraid of sharks and we know in san
francisco
there's
sharks of plenty there so i don't want
to hit a ball in that area
yeah that's why i'm skipping the cubby
cove
i'm not bi
on a boat out there case especially not
battling
no scotty i think you would dude you're
one of those guys that you know you like
to do stuff like that you wouldn't mind
the sharks either i love the one i love
when madison bumgarner um when muncie
hit it off bumgarner there and and he
said something to muncie much said hey
go get it out of the water
we'll go get this one case trivia
question the cincinnati red in
pittsburgh hitting the first ever home
run at this ballpark which was born in
2001 that was an on april 9th forever
part of pirates history
hey i let guys i left 70 i left 70
tickets for that game 70 tickets i left
so when i home and i was like oh yeah i
got i give the uh family and friends
their money's worth
and mrs white to stallings
sean casey a 314 career hitter at pnc
park you saw the ball well there huh
well i was so bad at three rivers
stadium because i was i felt like i was
still a fan with my dad at the game i
was like i i think i hit a buck 50 there
so when pnc opened i was like yes at
least
i don't feel like a fan of pnc i feel i
feel like a legit player
and that was a pretty good lineup the
red legs throughout there you got kicker
feet junior uh a couple guys that go
deep but you're the one who hit that
home run that's pretty impressive
yeah well we had some we had some good
we had some bobbers jared in those
lineups we just didn't have to pitch him
but adam dunn and austin kearns and and
griffey and dimitri young and pokey
reese we had some we had some guys that
could swing it
wow and sean i just got the splits at
the old park in pittsburgh what was it
179 did i hear 170.
it was so bad it was so frustrating
i'd be sitting in the dugout of three
rivers and i think to myself hey this is
really cool we're at the bucco game and
i'm like no i'm hitting third i actually
have to go get some hits and i would
just
brown ground out every time it was so
frustrating that's why they knocked it
down and started over for you
exactly thank you thank you
stalling solidly struck up the middle
but the dodgers have a man there
ah the shift
two outs
really good ball striking there but not
smart hitting
rope right at the second base
[Music]
mckinstry is there to put away stallings
and that brings us to philip evans two
for two
singles in the second and the fourth
today
pitch number 85 from maurice
and we talked to manager dave roberts he
wanted julio to be efficient today pitch
deep in the ball games
up until this point he's done just that
85 pitches
and we're in the sixth inning
he's giving his manager a pretty good
start
evans clocks it to left and there's
beatty
a one two three sixth just like he
pulled off in the fifth only five outs
yesterday from gonzalon so maria says
hey bullpen i got you today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
williams going back at the wall
goodbye
grand slam
game busted wide open
an 11 run first inning
on
hits the ball the other way deep to
right field reddick's going back at the
wall albert
his first dodger home run
his
668th career big league home run is his
first as a los angeles dodger and look
at the joy that he's playing with right
now
the 1-0
[Applause]
some air into this building and
especially into that dugout
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
new for us this season
this beautiful hardware the youtube
player of the game trophy if you're
watching on your mobile device or on a
computer you vote you decide who will
receive this custom trophy name engraved
on it makes this one extra special break
up things in the regular season for the
players stay tuned for the player of the
game polling options later in the show
and we'll talk to that player after the
game is complete live on youtube to a
global audience today the dodgers
for the pirates three inning number
seven beginning in pittsburgh
and it looks like we're in good shape
with the rain for the rest of the day
over under odds courtesy of bed mgm
the line was set at eight
and so far
pitching ruling at least enough slightly
a 4-3 game we're staying under and we'll
see if the bullpens can keep it that way
as the pirates actually
have their relievers as their strength
of the team and the dodgers pin has been
really solid in this series there's
justin turner fouling one off to the
left side but jared yesterday tony
gonzalen made his season debut coming
off a shoulder issue only picked up five
outs and then the dodgers said we'll
handle it from here and they did so well
in a tight win
the dodgers bullpen all season long has
been outstanding and you know yesterday
dave roberts wanted linked out of tony
gosselin making his first start
uh very uncharacteristic five walks for
tony last night and that's why as you
see a line drive
right in the glove of reynolds there by
jt
hard hit ball but dave roberts said it
was so important for julio to pitch deep
in the ball game because last night it
turned into a bullpen game
nice little extra squeeze in center from
brian reynolds to hold on to the
baseball started the year in the corner
pirates couldn't find what they were
looking for in center field
they said okay brian let's see what you
got
center fielder on the other side cody
ballinger one for three today
and single in the third inning
and eventually he scored
dwayne underwood jr back to work the 26
year olds
who pitched on tuesday jerry
jerry that's the pitch right there 90 95
down the middle it just seems like
bellinger's a little late on the heater
is that what you've been seeing
like so far
from him yeah we've seeing that so far
we have you got to remember cody
bellinger missed two months of the
season and really didn't have a spring
training because he had shoulder surgery
in the off season so he's kind of behind
he doesn't have a whole lot of bats this
year so it's timing's just a hair off i
think that the dodgers would like cody
belger now with two strikes he'll really
shorten up and look to put the ball
in play like he did his last at-bat
digs for
how one that
he's got incredible hands he's a great
athlete and you know before two strikes
hey let it rip you know try to hit the
ball 450 feet but do the little ichiro
swing here with two strikes little
combio down in the way he barrels it up
look at that swing right there head down
on contact great concentration shorten
up he gets the hit out of it love to see
it
i love it right there it's it did you
you got to compete sometimes with two
strikes two strikes you don't need to be
up there taking a big rip compete your
swing doesn't have to look perfect he's
out front his legs are gone but he does
a great job of waiting and just flipping
it to left
and with his speed
ball in the gap it'll be a two run ball
game that's why you always fight you
know if you're cody ballinger uh uh
mookie bets fight with two strikes to
get on base because
your speed is a difference maker
beatty on the ground left side and he
comes through
bellinger showing off the wheels and
he'll get to third easily runners on the
corners now with one out in the seventh
and there's that shift again it comes
into play i'm shocked that they're
shifting on matt batey he handles the
bat he goes the other way he sees that
the left side is open and you know what
i'm gonna hit a hard ground ball and get
a base hit out of it great approach
you can see the speed of cody flying
around second base
yeah nothing better when the ball's in
front and you just know you can take it
run right in the guy's face
back to back base hits here's mckinstry
and especially now with a run-run ball
game underwood is looking for something
down
hoping for a ground ball double play and
if you're zach mckenster you're looking
for the pitch up
at the very least you want to hit a sac
fly
to push that run across make it a two
run ball game
did he go
no
mckinstry was off to a fast start
this season quickly making a name for
himself
he was leading all rookies with 14 rbis
on the 20th of april when he hit the
injured list with a strained oblique
a little quieter since he returns smacks
that one past the infield and the
dodgers have a two-run
lead bellinger comes in it's 5-3
that's why that first and third
situation there is so important they got
first and third with bellinger there it
opens up that hole on the right side and
mckissery does a great job i think that
was a change up and he just hooks it
sometimes yeah there's a change-up that
backs up and sometimes as a hitter when
you feel you got that hole you just try
and shoot it on the ground to make sure
you can get that guy in from see that
hole right there there's a i remember
joel skinner telling me my first year in
proba is a lot of money in that four
hole when you got a guy on first and
third where you can where you could
shoot it and that's a great piece of
hitting right there
that's a great point there casey your
confidence as a hitter skyrockets when
you know all you have to do is get a
ball in the air and a guy like cody
bellinger's on third base i can get at
least a sac fly so i'm looking for high
contact he gets hard contact you get a
base hit and an rbi dodgers have action
first and second
only one out
and david bednar warming up he's got
great stuff
in the bullpen for the pirates but hey
it's like our production crew and jerry
hairston jr when they were setting up
the pregame they said we need to show
the variety that the dodgers offense
brings to the table this year you had
the bets homer but since then
timely hitting from the dodgers scoring
in a variety of ways
and that's something that mookie betts
emphasized last season when he first got
uh he came over the dodgers hey we need
a score if we want to be a championship
team we need to score in a variety of
ways yes the long ball is cool but we
have to execute sac flies move the
move the ball all over the diamond and
execute and the dodgers have done that
so far today
eight hits for la one homer
seven singles including one from lux
you can see gavin luck's last month or
so he's been so calm at the plate a lot
more confident knowing
uh that his talent is really starting to
show at the big league level
[Applause]
he was the best player in the minor
leagues in 2019
called up late that season
played in the postseason for the dodgers
that year
you can see
his numbers advancing to another level
since the month of may
1-2
i think one thing with lux too nobody's
going to play every day as a player
you know when you know you're playing
every day and you're gonna be in there
man it's it's you can relax and know
that man if i'm over four i'm not coming
out of the lineup you know i get a
chance to really settle in and get my
rhythm going to get my timing going
every day
that's a great point
i think a player especially a young
player always
needs to feel needed
see bickford getting ready
in the bullpen you always want to feel
needed and with the injuries to corey
seeger and cody bellinger was on the
aisle at the time he realized hey this
team needs me they need me to be that
star player i was in the minor leagues
and he has certainly performed rising to
the occasion and that's ball four
bases loaded up for the dodgers
yeah lux
he's so wise beyond his years with a
phrase that stood out to me in spring
training
after a really down 2020 and didn't
start the season on the big league
roster he said it's probably a good
thing in my career to struggle early on
learn how to deal with it learn how to
deal with failure well now there's been
some success for him and maybe more
coming for the dodgers they lead by two
one of the big arms for the pirates
bednar coming in
[Music]
you want numbers
oh he had the numbers
[Applause]
four batting titles
15 all-star games
12 gold gloves
[Applause]
with clemente it was so much more than
that
watch the old film and you see an artist
at work
an artist who painted with his bat
and his glove
[Music]
his legs and that unbelievable right arm
roberto clementi feels the ball and
displays his rifle arm he's gonna try
for third it may be close
he's out
greatest right feeler in the game of
baseball roberto clemente
like any great artist
his work just looked a little different
than everybody else's
and with clemente that work was
absolutely connected to where he came
from
pittsburgh they call in the great one
this man has just impressed me so much
and i'll never forget clementine
[Music]
[Music]
push your favorite players to the top
this summer with the 2021 google mlb
all-star ballot vote daily at mlb.com
vote and on google by searching mlb
all-star vote to send them to denver
colorado
and the ballot features two phases of
voting to elect the starters so head to
mlb.com vote or search it on google mlb
all-star vote
vote for some of your favorites phase
one is underway now
through june 24th then we pick top three
players at each position plus nine
outfielders of course
as we continue along and eventually
announce starters
on the night of july one this is david
bednar
maybe a reliever makes it to the
all-star game for pittsburgh they have a
few viable options
bednar of course their closer
rodriguez has been awesome so far this
year adam frazier is a candidate so is
bryan reynolds and we know the dodgers
are loaded
with all-star candidates and their
manager dave roberts will be
representing the nl in the dugout as the
skipper austin barnes with a big chance
here base is loaded just one gone
bednar brings serious heat
96 a bit off the plate and barnes fouls
it away
three times a base on balls so far this
afternoon for barnes
265 but the base is loaded in his career
including one grand slam
there's that line case that's the
distance needed
to bring home matt beatty from third
with a sac fly
where was
yeah exactly
where was it
in the brain bednar's been really
bednar's been really good this year guys
at stranding inherited runners
and and and also with runners in scoring
position not letting those guys score so
we'll see what happens here if he can
if he can really attack barnes he could
really go for a purse for a strikeout
right here
the count is in his favor 2-1 for austin
barnes looking for a fastball here
barnes weekly on the ground bednar goes
home and they get the force so now two
down
[Applause]
really good play there by bednar hopping
off that mound
making sure he got the out at the plate
and a pretty good athlete he's a big
dude i'm going to see him hop off this
mountain here
and make the play
who says pitchers aren't athletes here
you know i mean
this is actually i say that all the time
but that is athletic
very active and i wouldn't say that
betnar cause he looks like a big dude
you'd be in trouble
[Music]
well the dodgers are going for it
chris taylor coming up with the bases
loaded and two outs in the seventh
[Music]
and we talked about max muncie earlier
about being a team's mvp or really a
co-mvp where here's the other guy ct3
he's as valuable as it gets to the dodge
can play anywhere 33 rbis leads the ball
club
runs scored as well just been an
important piece to the dodgers
and he's gonna give you a great at-bat
right i mean this guy sees a lot of
pitches doesn't waste a
pitch what a weapon for dave roberts to
have on the on the on the bench right
what a weapon to have for him to have
you sit chris taylor to start the game
but you're still able to bring him up in
a huge situation in the seventh
and have a good matchup against bednar
in there 02.
chris taylor excellent fastball hitter
with the bases loaded bednar first two
pitches breaking balls a knee buckling
curveball right here
now
02.
[Music]
that pitch was the spider
not a word you hear every day well
maria's has the slurve
splitter slider mix from bednar
see what he dials up on the o2
got him
serious breaking stuff from bednard to
compliment the big time fastball
look at him go
in a major bind he comes in prevents
further damage but the dodgers have a
two run cushion
as we head to the bottom of the seventh
let's stretch
it's time for ask the dodgers where the
players answer some questions submitted
by the fans
my questions for mookie bets i just want
to start the question off by saying
you're a huge role model in my life as a
baseball player and i was just wondering
you know who had a big influence on your
life growing up
thank you for supporting me and
doing what i can to be a role model to a
lot of kids so thank you for that and
i would say probably just my parents you
know
both of them are huge role models
for me the way they treated people the
way they went about all their business
they definitely put everlasting
impressions on me and i'm trying to do
the the same for for the next generation
hey cody congratulations on winning the
world series and best wishes for a great
2021 season
my question to you is what advice would
you give to your younger self during the
little week world series as a world
series champion
um to just enjoy it
don't take it too seriously but have fun
and
play the game
hard bellinger takes that one to left
field goodbye another home run
cody ballinger still ridiculous
[Applause]
thanks for watching ask the dodgers
a little seventh inning stretch some
time to think about the
mlb game of the week live on youtube
player
of the game
who gets the trophy like pete alonso did
last week with the game-winning rbi
against the diamondbacks this trophy
means something
competitive players in the sport want to
add every single piece of hardware to
the resume we'll unveil that poll later
let's cap off this one where would you
most want your home run to land and the
winner
mccovey cove
40 percent of the pie i'll give you some
of the comments from our creators too
ashley sanders said mccovey cove for me
it would be a big splash
i like this one from the pittsburgh
pirates channel allegheny river it can
float away and i can say i hit one
hundreds of miles
that's good i like that
for the allegheny river i'm not a big
fan of because it sounds like too much
love alligators
you know again sharks alligators not a
fan you're scaring me jerry
there's no alligators in the allegheny
river i promise you
how do you know that
how do you know that
i just know there might be a couple
tires in there but there's no there's no
alligators
eric gonzalez
tom and kevin newman coming up this
inning for the pirates and the new
pitcher for la is phil bickford
phil last pitch on saturday in atlanta
scoreless inning just 13 pitches
heavy fastball guy uses the four
foreseemer 80 of the time
goes off speed it's one and two
he's been a fine for the dodgers you
know a lot of injuries
that they've had with their bullpen
he's been asked to come in and
and and pitch in later in the innings
sometimes the seventh eighth inning to
get ki outs he's done a great job
and he strikes out gonzalez
that's a filthy slider right there
bigfoot rears back man look at this the
deception of that pitch it looks like
it's right down the middle as a hitter
when you see it right about there you
think it's a fastball and it just leaves
you
great pitch
and that's why
in case that's why the fastball's so
important when you get ahead with that
fastball
you know and that slider is basically on
the same plane of that fastball it's
very deceptive and tough to hit
i mean that's some serious horizontal
movement
on his slider
mostly a two pitch guy
there's the heat
jp
the dodgers have what a few arms that
can get the job done what do you think
[Music]
well one through four scott it's hard to
think of a better rotation anywhere in
baseball and the bullpen has been solid
as usual but i would say that pitching
depth in general will be a focus of this
team at the trade deadline consider what
happened in last night's game tony
gonzalon in his very first outing in the
major leagues this season one and
two-thirds innings
five walks five walks i think with
gonzalon's struggles last night of
course dustin may out for the year
they'll watch gonsled carefully but when
you consider how much they like having
david price and jimmy nelson in the
bullpen there might be a spot scott for
a a swing type pitcher who can either
start for you or be a bulk innings guy
like they had with dustin may last year
in october that role seems available for
this team going forward
thanks jp
now two and two
to kai tom
wow bickford is producing some
pretty ugly swings from the first couple
hitters that he's faced case it looks
like it's been tough to pick up the
baseball
man it looks like that fastball's riding
that 93-94 looks a little more a little
harder the way some of the swings these
guys are taking looks like more like
96-97
well well guys you know twitter is
something else
i just got tweeted out by rob perky this
is from the pittsburgh
post gazette
another alligator found roaming
pittsburgh so definitely there are
alligators
near or in that river
i think it's just a university of
florida graduate it's a florida gator
they're confusing things
oh my god
i'm telling you october 2nd 2019 guys
watch out alligators roaming the swamps
the river look out
i have never seen an alligator out there
in that river i'm telling you i've swam
with those rivers before i didn't come
out too clean but i was swimming in them
[Music]
3-2 kai tom broke his bat
shallow center who's got it it's taylor
okay so la is trying to pick things up
in a very competitive division they're
36 and 25 and they have dominated
against the five worst teams in the
national league they're 17 and two and
then look what's coming up a last place
texas rangers team
a decent philadelphia philly squad then
the worst club in baseball the arizona
diamondbacks then the gauntlet padres
cubs giants so a chance for the dodgers
to get on quite a roll until they run
into the padres again la going for a
third consecutive win this afternoon
a little soft spot in the schedule
guys i played for manager dusty baker
and he always emphasized
when you're playing teams you're
supposed to beat you have to make sure
you do not lose your concentration
continue to play your game and really
dusty never
gave pep talks weren't facing teams that
were let's say the elite teams because
he knew his teams would get up for those
games
kevin newman
into left center
that's zach mckinstry newly out there he
can play wherever
three up three down in the seventh
as the pirates trail by a couple runs at
pnc park a good one here on youtube this
afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
great baseball right there and that
one's gonna go
that ball was crushed
strike three
that was a great play
[Applause]
[Music]
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball and
a little bit of drizzling going on again
the pnc and the sky is getting darker
all right cove at 19 vaccines are safe
and effective join the team and get the
vaccine to help get us all get back to
doing what we love together visit
mlb.com
covid19 resources for more information
dodgers five pirates three heading to
the eighth
scott braun shawn casey jerry hairston
jr jp morosi
and the pirates
cueing kyle crick to take over another
excellent reliever era in the one and a
half range so far this year best part of
the pirates has been the bullpen case so
when they do have a lead
they can seal the deal and that's why
you've actually seen quite a few close
wins and losses for the pirates because
even if a starter struggles
like mitch keller today
bullpen has been really solid doing
their job all season long as the rain
gets a little heavier now
no shelter has had a great bullpen out
there crick has been really really good
batting average against .061 this guy's
been really filling up the strike zone
there just as i say that mookie pets get
to knock the left of course he does
third time reaching today second hit of
the afternoon a walk a homer and now a
base hit
he's really looked good and comfortable
at the plate really the last couple
nights
uh here in pittsburgh he gets a breaking
ball outer third gets the barrel on it
rifles it to left for a lead off single
just the fourth hit allowed by kyle
crick
all season
that's amazing
pretty good speed i know the rain's
coming down slick conditions but mookie
betts always a threat to steal a base
oops
and bets off to second
oh
tough to hold on to the baseball too now
but that was
called dead on a timeout
bets going ah just in case i'm gonna
take second okay
yeah i know we're at the top of the
order max muncie uh hitting second but
the guy we haven't talked about so far
today is albert pujols guys albert
pujols has been
on fire ever since he put on that dodger
uniform has been big off the bench
and in spot starts
jerry have you got a chance to talk to
him at all is he is he happy with his
role in la is he you know content with
with how they're using them
i haven't had a chance to talk to him
personally but he's been on our
on air in l.a as buki's running on the
pitch foul ball
but to get back to albert he's been all
smiles and i've talked to clayton
kershaw and kirsch says kershaw told me
that he has been the happiest he's never
seen him he's really energized this ball
club because you remember before signing
our pool so the dodgers were a little
bit of a lull
weren't playing very very good baseball
the defense uh wasn't you know as
up to their standard offense wasn't up
to their standard but albert pools
injected life to this team and he has
been an incredible teammate guys love
him and his production has been there i
mean he's swinging the bat key rbis
and i believe he has four or five home
runs in that dodger uniform and manager
dave roberts is going to use him them
you know wisely they're not going to run
him out there every day but he's going
to get enough at bats
and keep him irrelevant
and it gives the dodgers four former
mvps on their roster only four teams in
baseball history
have been able to say that it seems like
an ideal fit
first off he didn't have to move much
going for the angels from the angels to
the dodgers and there's the teams with
four former mvp winners 96 sacks 82
angels
and the big red machine in 1978 with
rose morgan foster
and johnny bench but albert pujols is
the oldest player in major league
baseball
he moves over from the angels and
continues his 21-year career and finds a
home with la when not only were they
going through a lull but they needed
some help specifically against
left-handed pitching and that's where
albert has thrived this year
and another another point there scott
you know the dodgers you know like a lot
of clubs they use analytics
but they also understand the importance
of having good character great clubhouse
guys veteran presence in years past
they've had david freeze they've had
chase utley now albert pujols he
provides not only production but also
leadership those intangibles that
championship teams need
i think he'd love to grab another ring
suitcase before the career is all said
and done he's got two
that's why he's there brony i really
believe that and i i was fortunate
enough to play against him most of the
time most of my career was in the nl
central i got to see pools when he came
up in 0-1
and and then for the next i think six
years um
it was unbelievable i'd never seen
anything like it the way this guy could
just
line the line gap to gap he would hit a
ball to right center look like a power
hitting lefty hit at man it was just
never gave a pitch away he walked more
than he struck out it was a clinic when
you watched him hit
full count pitch
do another
statcast powered by google cloud
let's look at the splits
four long balls with the dodgers he went
deep five times with the angels and
there it is shawn he can send it to all
parts of the ballpark actually for a few
seasons late in his career he was
primarily primarily just pull power but
he's gone back to spraying the baseball
with power all over
and he's done it well for the dodgers so
far in his short time with the team that
misses to muncie ball four now two on
for la
but you think about the valuable bench
roll
that albert pujols has provided behind
max muncie at first especially when
muncie has dealt with the right ankle
sprain in the past week or so
it's a pretty nice backup to have if
you're la
[Music]
jp what else do you have for us on pool
holes and actually before that are we
going to be able to keep rolling with
this game how's the weather out there
sure scott well the forecast here in the
beautiful city of pittsburgh calls for
some rain with a chance of alligators
wait did i say alligators no i i think
we're gonna be okay i see no alligators
here i am by the way the member of the
broadcast crew most closely positioned
to the river i see no gators let's make
that clear number one and number two on
albert i think one thing i'll mention
here
one of the people in the organization in
the front office for the dodgers placido
polanco of course one of sean's former
teammates in detroit he's one of
albert's closest friends in the world
and so i really think that relationship
when albert was thinking about what he
wanted to do next yeah some people were
maybe surprised he went to an nl team
but i think more than anything guys he
wanted to go to a place where he knew it
was all about winning where he knew the
people there he trusted them and i
really think that relationship with
placido polanco in the front office and
just knowing to jerry's point and
desean's point what the dodgers were all
about was a huge reason why albert
signed here
[Music]
thanks james that's a great point there
by john
you know just knowing the organization
and alvaro pools understands you know
what i may got one possibly two years
left of my career i want to make them
the most of the next year or two and
la was certainly the best fit for him
turner sends a ball to center and it
will fall on a weird spin and score a
run
mookie bets come on down dodgers
doubling up the pirates 6-3 in the
eighth in rainey pnc park
yeah we just got done talking about
these pools
did you the steal that bets had earlier
he stole that base on crick boom he went
from second to third no big deal set
this up for first and third for turner
to hit a little you know off the end of
the bat
to center field bet scores easily
[Applause]
yeah we talked about mookie bets max
muncie cc3 and our pools but really what
the heartbeat of this ball club the last
five or six years especially for the
lineup has been justin turner you know
we joke around mr jt the red dream but
he definitely has been that he has been
the coaches manager's dream filling him
in that in that three hole knowing that
you're going to get production and he's
been the perfect three-hole hitter
for the dodgers the last five or six
years
bellinger in the cleanup spot pujols on
deck rain coming down pretty good
here in the eighth
that's base hit
up to second on the muncie walk
bet steals third
and comes home on the turner single
now bellinger
[Music]
so
look at kyle crick three hits allowed in
his first 17 appearances and the dodgers
say
so what
we've got two today
nobody out in the eighth
[Applause]
we'll see if that's good enough for
hayes to grab
and he got it
wow
what a play he made that catch what a
oh my gosh
what a play right here by brian hayes on
the tarp i mean he has to go so far
i'd have to say he went over 100 feet to
get this ball looks like and look how
nice and easy he comes this is an
unbelievable tough play just nonchalant
right by the tarp makes the play wow
unbelievable
so many great athletes in the game today
we saw mookie betts earlier now hayes
over the shoulder catching at the tarp
rain pouring down cody bellinger can't
believe it
ranging far down the left field line he
can't believe it incredible play by
hayes
that's a future gold glover right there
if
nolan aronado ever wants to give up
his status
in the national league but key brian
hayes already looks like one of the best
in the biz at the hot corner
and now here's albert
[Music]
out all right so sean casey talked as
much as anyone
i'd say in major league history at first
base with opposing base runners so were
there ever any convos with this guy an
all-time great
oh with albert i had many conversations
with albert yeah i always pick his brain
about hitting i'm like how do you hit
line drives all over the place with with
the authority that you hit hit it with
him
one of them was i remember him talking
to me he was talking about really like
staying on top of the ball he's like i
remember one day he was like case just
do what i do just i try to just come
down on the ball and then drive it to
right center i'm like man you make it
look too easy brother it's not that easy
[Applause]
great guy though many a conversation
great guy
sean you mentioned that you got a chance
to play and you were fortunate enough to
play against albert all those years well
i was unfortunate to play against albert
because i played for the cubs the
brewers the reds it needs to kill our
teams
he's one of the best hitters i've ever
seen
incredible top hand
looks like the umpires are going to get
together i think let's talk to the
grouse crew
yeah they want to check out the radar i
mean you can see it
you can hear it
wherever you're watching from worldwide
on youtube
6-3 dodgers in the 8th
yeah it's tarp time
so three days in a row in pittsburgh
the game
will step aside for a moment
thanks to mother nature
this happened on tuesday and wednesday
to delay the start
of the game
this time we make it to the eighth
and here comes the tarp
[Music]
guys i've been so spoiled i played for a
lot of ball clubs my last two years with
the dodgers now i'm here in la
here at dodger stadium i don't even see
a tarp
beautiful skies here in l.a but again
east coast is different
east coast is different
you gotta delay
well you get the seasons out in the
northeast
the variety just like the dodger offense
this year
but it's been a lot of the same this
week
precipitation in pittsburgh dodgers with
10 hits today six runs to show for it
six hits for pittsburgh
to account for their three runs this
afternoon
in a game that started with mitch keller
and julio urias thanks to mother nature
and the game never came back jim beam
game summary dodger six pirates three
it's called
in the eighth
but mookie bets came back and gave us an
awesome interview nice chatting with him
as he homered for the sixth time this
season and the first time since mid-may
well i thought we could sneak in a game
in the steel city without some rain in
this series jp i thought you were gonna
bring sunshine all day you did for about
three quarters of the time but what did
you see my friend
well thank you scott i appreciate it and
by the way thank you for including in
that highlight
zach mckinstry who played his college
ball in my home state central michigan
university by the way they made it to
the ncaa tournament this year so
inspired probably by zach's continued
success with the los angeles dodgers
loved mookie betz's game i think one
thing i'll add in addition to what we've
already covered so far you could tell
guys late in the game kyle crick never
got comfortable on the mound because of
mookie's speed just the threat of
mookie's speed did not let crick settle
in and i think that's just emblematic of
the winning baseball that mookie plays
and by translation the way the rest of
the team plays and now you see bellinger
come back some better at bats today i
thought corey seeger is out there where
certainly we'll see him come back too
put this in perspective the dodgers when
you consider mookie not really being
mooky for the first two months of the
season ballinger missing time seeger
missing time guys they still have the
best run differential in baseball so if
you wanted to get this team early you
might have missed your chance because
they're now only a game and a half
behind the giants the padres we have
seen they have lost seven of ten their
offense is struggling do we see them
make a move for joey gallo and now the
san francisco giants feeling the heat of
course they play the washington
nationals later on tonight they must
face max scherzer so if max wins that
game they're only now at the dodgers a
game back max sherzo by the way could be
a really interesting trade possibility
maybe back to his home city of st louis
for scherzer with the nationals but i
have to tell you guys jerry i was
listening early on i think it was all
cosmically connected because the team
the dodgers are chasing right now the
giants they're sending a former florida
gator to the mound anthony sclafani
tonight
good call jp that's so good disco on the
mound for the giants they have found
some gems on the free agent market from
the off-season dodgers win it 6-3 over
the pirates yeah it's a competitive nl
west they'll head back home we'll keep
things rolling on the post game show
next
and look who's coming up
he comes out on one leg
on one leg he comes out
and with two out you talk about a roll
of the dice this is it
three and two
we get to the two count as soon as
zachary goes said i say time out
[Applause]
i look right at accuracy and i say
partner
sure as you're standing here breathing
you're going to see that 3 2 back door
slider
but the game right now is at the plate
high fly ball into right field she is
gone
when he hit that home run i was like
you gotta be kidding me even when you're
running out there you're like did this
just happen did this really happen
in a year that has been so improbable
the impossible has happened
it's the post game show presented by jim
beam and you're looking at the longest
win streak against the pirates in
dodgers franchise history that was
matched today and it's still going
you go back to 1952
may 4th through july 20th they won 13 in
a row against pittsburgh and same story
it's a wrap around streak that goes from
2018
up until today many thanks to mookie
betts this afternoon who gave the
dodgers an early lead three pitches into
the contest and congrats moody mookie
you are
the youtube player of the game we
already did the interview fan said give
us mookie on the post game show we
delivered we read your mind we knew he
was going to win with the homer with the
defense with the way that he leads this
ball club and leads the vote by far as
we put a lid on it 72 percent say mookie
bets was the best that we saw this
afternoon in the game between the
dodgers and the pirates and jerry
hairston they had a great point i think
the people spoke and i think they were
correct
they were definitely correct mookie his
abilities were on full display great
offense with a lead off home run love
the speed with the stolen base net play
in right field guys i am still
mesmerized by that play outstanding
throwing arm and accurate yeah he does
it all sean and he's a fun interview too
and i remember i asked him i said how do
you make it look just so chill and he's
like i don't know and even the way he
answered the question was just like
i'm i'm like that i'm cool i was born
cool everything i do is smooth and i'm
pretty much good at everything you know
i can beat you in bowling i can beat you
in baseball you name it right if if
there's like you know a big uh jar full
of jelly beans he's probably gonna guess
the correct number he does it all
if you're playing marbles with mookie
betts buckle up he's going to beat you
you know he's going to take you down and
anything he can i think one thing about
mookie bets is we really got to see all
his tools today just the way he started
off with the power got another hit in
the game came up throwing got a chance
to show his arm stole some bases i mean
he really did everything today and uh
and and he no doubt deserves player of
the game yes he does most lead off home
run since the start of 2014 it's
springer it's blackman
and then it is mookie betts on the other
side bravo to adam frazier and i always
give props to our players each week on
youtube that say hey mike me up listen
to the real stuff going on down at the
fields and this is what adam frazier was
talking about today on youtube
oh yeah how are we uh
like 3 50 going into may like 250 now
those are like the first couple of hits
i've had really felt like it was a long
year man wrong year i need this cloud
cover all day
all right let's go
go
go go go
they might need a translator on this
thing
the words across the bottom of the
screen
uh-oh
i guess that's why he's not out huh
what's up
don't i i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
literally would have hit me in the mouth
i didn't hit it listen there we go let's
go
let's go
play
it's all in the hair
so it's all in the hair
[Applause]
you got anything for me
i said 100 bucks all right
oh wait dude
seriously might be the worst bass runner
in the league
[Applause]
i don't like that one
that's a tough one
[Applause]
we got rain coming in we ain't gonna be
able to play no more
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what i'm saying man that's messed
up
hot out here man for like an hour and a
half so let's get the hell out of here
then
adam frazier miked up today on youtube
we appreciate it adam that was fun and
justin turner owes you 100 bucks
apparently 13-game hit streak for
frasier as they call him in the steel
city nine extra base hits during that
time period
ops really great in the past couple
weeks but on the year this is a
potential all-star candidate for the
pirates assuming he's still with the
team by the time we reach the all-star
break just because he's a free agent
after next season case so it's possible
that adam frazier is helping out another
contending team by the time we get to
july
yeah i'd be surprised if he keeps
playing the way he's playing that might
be a good trade piece for the pirates
and somebody like the a club like the
yankees or something that could use a
good contact hitter in their lineup he
seems like a good dude always thinking
about the game has fun little one-liners
too jerry it was nice to get an inside
peek at the life of adam frazier on the
field
absolutely this guy's fun to watch and
he's a really good baseball player kind
of a throwback baseball player great
back to ball skills i'll tell you what
if he doesn't stay with the pirates he
is a trade candidate he's going to make
a club very happy any team can use an
adam frazier playing anywhere anywhere
in the order
contact hitter you love it who will be
mic'd up for us next week when we have
matt best version rajay davis mark
gubizza and alex curry bringing you the
call of the mlb game of the week live on
youtube tigers angels it's a nighttime
affair 9 38 eastern time first pitch
i'll be part of that pregame show at
around nine o'clock so this one is
complete back on june 17th a week from
today coverage gets rolling 30 minutes
before that one and we'll remind you
about upcoming games with a little
notification if you hit the bell icon so
for the heavy hitters sean casey jerry
hairston jr the ivy leaguer jp morocci
and our whole all-star crew i'm scott
brown logging out for now dodgers win in
an eighth inning shortened game 6-3
we'll talk next week when we're back for
more live baseball on youtube